whatsapp è buy back up il sospetto di
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
meraviglioso video di papi girls
buongiorno a tutti buon salda e quando
stai guardando questo video magari nel
2065 quando studieranno la storia e
troveranno chi è questo qua che ha fatto
due 200 episodio episodi di sto schifo
di yo yo soy lorenzo studi mi chiamo
faccio io giochi su youtube fa cioè pil
wheels e siamo arrivati alla fissazione
200 o che bello raiano vedo l'ora di
dirlo a mia madre dopo glielo dico
adesso giochiamo e perché queste tre ore
incredibili è che dobbiamo fare
insomma spero siano di vostro gradimento
anche perché comunque è uno dei giochi
no è il gioco più rappresentativo del
mio canale perché comunque ha previsto
ragazzi c'è da quant'è che faccio è più
dal 2000 e inizio 2013 perché lo porto
sul canale perché data ci gioco anche da
ci giocavo anche un po prima win sono
sette anni quasi otto anni di f.liszt
ben se la mia sanità mentale non andata
[ __ ] perché comunque questo gioco
insomma non è così deteriorante o forse
non sono io che sono fatto d'amianto ma
con un altro discorso allora ragazzi
voglio vedere se riesco a mettere un
timer fry un bel tyner one gigantesco
adesso vogliono ammetterlo
sarebbe molto interessante farlo perché
ragazzi siccome così come quando faccio
se live mi piace mettere diner per
conteggiare quanto supplizio sto
sopportando sarebbe molto carino farlo
se riesco e se non ostica chi allora
output
la mettiamo
questa roba qua la chiamo tre ore 03
aspetta start ok allora fronte vedere se
riesco a pizzicarlo ok
raga lo metto lo metto qua in live metto
smetto la simbolo di quanti di quanti
minuti sono passati lo metto
allora facciamo così tanto da ok
resto ok
non mi ricordo come si fa perché è da
una vita che non lo faccio ok l'ho fatto
ma posso
la novità dito nemmeno metta parto
ragazzi dal momento in cui gioco e
adesso non è il momento in cui gioco
parte non mi ricordo che mi salva il
file mannaggia al cacchio devo farla
prima sta roba
o che hanno trovato posto
eccoci
teoricamente dovrei aver fatto
ci sono era che un attimo nagel cacchio
dovevo farlo prima però fa niente
ok
ok ragalo messo aspettato vedere come
farlo apparire ma l'ho messo dove
cacchio è non ha già il vicolo
eccolo qua perfetta va bene ci siamo
allora questo il timer
ci siamo
bene
ciao ciao ragazzi stavo facendo un test
meraviglioso allora questo è il timer
questo è il timer qua perfetto allora
impact bene bene all right perfetto
allora ragazzi nuovi spiego che cacchio
staffa è per chi si è connesso adesso
perché sono andato online sono entrato
adesso in live dove spiego che cacchio
staffa
eccolo qua
ok
sto mettendo un timer che adesso useremo
ragazzi perché è così
we buenos
allora ciao signori tutto a posto allora
questo un timer ok perfetto questa roba
serve perché oggi facciamo un bello
speciale di un gioco proprio bouquet che
uscito ieri stiamo valutando per chi è
entrato adesso perché ho switchato live
pubblica adesso mi va beh allora oggi
giochiamo a ex illis un gioco
sconosciuto
qua c'è il timer adesso io lo farò
ripartire perché adesso ecco vedi ma
dovrebbe ripartire di parte esatto
allora io adesso lo loro errori a 0 ok
lo stop
lo sto quello di essere perfetto quando
partiremo con happy meals a farlo
partire
allora ragazzi come tutto a posto allora
il discorso quale ai ragazzi il discorso
che grazie emanuele per la donazione
discorso è questo gioco è la mia rovina
non scherza notaio devo lamentare il mio
successo sta roba
il che è tutto dire comunque è una vita
che gioco happy meals saranno quante a
queste sono sette anni e mezzo
il discorso è che il 7 anni e mezzo mi
avete sempre detto porta lo porta lo
portano io mi sono frustato ma l'ho
portato oggi siamo al meraviglioso 2
centesimo episodio allo ragazzi dico non
erano cinque ore si però secondo me
ragazzi allora secondo me cinque ore
sono troppe perché dopo tre ore di è più
il se anche voi secondo me chi rompe le
balle quindi dopo tre ore che saranno
incredibili switcher o afol guys quindi
faremo tre ore di happy wheels mega che
sono tantissime per è più che faremo
solo livelli quelli fatti bene tre ore
mega
dopodichè switchable guys io se la live
questa qua la salvo la metto da parte
che il duecentesimo e bisogna poi
smiccio su bulgari gli ultimi due ore ok
ragazzi così almeno varie un po anche
cinque ore sono già tre sono secondo me
tantissimi va bene ci sta 5 sembra
esagerato se riusciamo a anche tre anche
tre esagerato però ho promesso la
sentita la canzoncina perché il momento
di morire no che adesso ci vediamo tra
gli ufficiali per la torre shaun totale
sono cinque ore di live si sentono
circoli live ragazzi finisce alle 8
[Musica]
l appello quello che l'ispezione ragazzi
ospitati dalle 15 alle 18
ap wells speciale speciale dalle 18 alle
20 face siate cm
allora adesso che è sistemata pure la
descrizione abbiamo tutto quello che ci
serve
signore e signori è arrivato il momento
di fare questa roba incredibile
partiamo adesso perché sennò fall guys
ritarda un botto
direi che possiamo partire prima di
partire fatemi sono settare al volo ogni
tanto c'è uno schermo intero poi ogni
tanto non c'è io sono 20 anni che gioca
sta roba ancora non ho capito
fa niente non otteneva schermo intero lo
teniamo così essendo io rai
facciamo così
a maggio il cacchio no
perfetto meraviglioso
a cacchio c'è una ricetta di sotto
ragazzi mi danno fastidio le righe zio
quando montevideo lo faccio lo faccio a
montare a giampiero sono di un preciso
su ste cose che non vede da allora
o che cacchio
perfetto signori ci siamo
e la storia appuntamento con la storia
allora metto il timer visto che è
sintonizzato adesso non abbiate ci sarà
il suo timer gigante fatevi provare un
attimo a vedere se funziona eccolo qua
un pelo più piccolo ma lo facciamo
fatica verso il formato non è a macchia
di sempre nel formato facciamo diciamo
così va che è un po meglio la facciamo
eccoci
ok
ok parto col timer ai ragazzi la adesso
si parte questa rocca che ho fatto
scusate questa roba sarà storica
sappiatelo sarà storica free to one
le star days ecco lo metto un po più
piccolo che se non ho un dito
nell'occhio
ok eccoci qua
molto bene ecco o ma spendono metto al
centro vaghe che fa più figo anzi ho
detto qua ci siamo ragazzi te che ha
posto va bene c'è un po più di contorno
così
eccoci o
meraviglioso allora tre ore di happy
meals sarà indimenticabile sta roba
grazie mille ginevra per l'agro nation
adesso vi leggo tutti e scusatemi stanno
gettando lino well commenta giacomo walk
for the drones loredana thank you for
the hub o nazione ginevra grazie ancora
di supporto grazie mille un bacio chiara
welcoming e giacomo epic gip epiche
moggi thank you for the donation my
brother grazie ragazzi se volete
supportarmi nella live come sapete tutti
quanti questo centro abbonati potete
abbonarvi e se no con la sua facciata
potete scrivermi qualcosa insomma a
mandarmi un messaggio io ve lo leggo
insomma io direi che possiamo partire
allora per questa live
io vi direi facciamo le cose belle
ok allora prime tre ore ribadisco ci
sarà filippo al quinto gioco ci sarà
togliamogli albert qua perché tanto ci
sono pagati purtroppo ragazzi sto
periodo quindi appena siri sbagliano
viaggiato vi leggo comunque secondo
nation leggo tutto tommy preoccupate
questa roba non si ripeterà mai più
ragazzi avete detto pensato perché tre
ore di ex che arriva dove ricotta e più
forte donation lino welcome anche per
giorgio grazie mille per la b diventa
allora partiamo dai livelli top al mondo
di april rialzo bene direi di giocare
almeno questi in partenza focus umide
giacomo e let's go allora io non ho mai
fatto sarò beh se se il buongiorno si
vede dal mattino
comunque fa pensavo scherza ripartiamo
la bocca un attimo sto leggendo knuble
and electric jason dal tetto grazie
mille per donazioni resto allora alcuni
livelli alcuni livelli ci sta che
l'abbiate magari anche già viste perché
io mi sto prendendo dalla classifica
mondiale dei livelli più votati di
fiducia dei siti per quindi quella
classifica che ogni tanto prendono i
video e faccio ma è raro insomma che io
faccia dei livelli dovevo cappelluti 15
st se siete miei fan da una vita ma cosa
è successo mai nella vita
calmiamoci se siete miei fan da una vita
ci sta che alcuni livelli li abbiate
anche qua ciclisti insomma negli ultimi
anni quindi io faccio la classifica
mondiale perché per il duecentesimo
episodio meritano solo i livelli
migliori al mondo agli alti quindi
preparatevi per l'intrattenimento su
etnies migliore della storia
se riesco aprire cava ca
di livello alucard grazie mille per la
nazione certo tanti auguri fascista il
cibo di compleanno giulia passa il
tiburio moon and games certo grazie
mille per hanno detto giulia grazie
mille
lo abbassa che mi sa che davano fastidio
a posto ma dovremmo essere giusti e
fatemi sapere mirko e diego
thank insomma le donazioni e per la hbo
nazione ditemi se va bene il volume
ragazzi allora questo è l'obiettivo è
finire il primo livello in tre ore
va bene tre ore di primo livello di el
speriamo di finirlo in 3 ore porca vacca
se no
veramente io questi sette anni di apple
i paesi e buttati nel cesso va bene
perfetto ragazzi io non so anche perché
faccio youtuber non ho idea ma fa niente
ok le slot lo metterei sul curriculum
sto coso se riesco a finire il primo
livello di tre ore di ep lewis ma perché
vai lento come mia nonna giovata non
c'ho fatto maledizione alla vita
tutto a posto comunque poi non gridare
mi dispiace zio 6 sul canale sbagliato
non è una smr questo qua è tutt'altro
che ragazzi park di una bacca morta ma
com'è possibile come ma cosa maraga ma
non è possibile mi sta impegnando un
sacco cioè questo è il primo esce dalla
crisi ecco il suo gioco da una vita così
vai avanti che c'è quello che arriva
e poi non è tanto lontano il traguardo
perché bisognava arrivare tra loro per
capire dove era e non è lontanissimo
joele alessandro e mirko grazie mille
per la buona azione per le donazioni
ragazzi e ci riprovo ah ho capito cosa
non fare ho capito cosa devo fare
devo andare piano perché perché sbatto
sulla palla da demolizione comprende
anche prendo il tubo lì ok
pensavo fosse molto più più difficile
che vale la pena per e vai vai anche suo
carico stavate buono porco chi mi ha
insegnato a giocare sto gioco ciuffo le
marcio grazie a telethon nation questo
livello durerà tre ore ragazzi
preparatevi insomma perché questo è il
livello più lungo se faccio passare le
cose poi vado dietro una brutta idea ma
non è che non so come farlo passare
visto che troppo veloce anche più di me
aiuto tutto a posto ragazzi rosa
senatore classe 1000 collaborazione
quando fino alle 17 va bene nel
ringrazio mille all'ora
allora allora no ragazzi io vi giuro è
veramente bisogno a meno che non debba
veramente farlo passare ma non so come
ma io ho mai fatto sto livello lega non
credo perché non mi ricordo di un
livello così in moto il primo è come se
uno è tecnicamente imponessero lo può
finire nessuno può fino cioè un nessuno
prendesse un po fino a questo livello e
la tara hanno fatto proprio fatti
sclerare e mettetelo prima della
classifica per continuare a giocare
all'infinito
ed è tutto un complotto del creatore di
et knicks ha detto voglio che continuino
a giocare a tetris per il resto della
loro vita
allora faccio come primo livello un
impossibile che non si può finire così
loro continueranno per sempre ottima
tattica anche devo fare un video youtube
che non finisce
si diventa il mio lavoro per sempre cosa
che
spetterebbe non inquadrano ragazzi ve lo
giuro prezzo veramente non so che
cacchio
era un tentativo di farlo passare non
sono ricerche non sarà che come perché
sono gigantesco come mi metto sotto ma
neanche morto riesco a mettermi arrivo
ma cosa ho preso un fienile in faccia va
benone a dopo quello che volevano ko
ok ok ok ok questo è buono questo è
buonissimo questo è buonissimo
[Musica]
il primo livello e lo completato andiamo
al prossimo cioè le grazie alla nazione
zaccheroni de giacomo devi pro loco
vinto e piergiorgio master noises grazie
per l'azione grazie mille a tutti quanti
ragazzi racers granger ho preso il muro
fratelli e che trova e doveva andare
così e doveva andare così fratelli un
altro passo basta co sti trattori in che
mi seguono mi sono incastrato nella
altalena mi sono incastrato non è
un'altalena un ponte
mi sono incastrato nel fronte dammi una
mano li ho cosa stai fermo lì a
guardarmi inutile essere inutile madonna
che vengo riguarda niente o oggi proprio
noi donna o che c'ha olio tutto ha poi
sono contento guardo lo meriti
ho capito ma va bene anche basta
salve è costa leggere gestito sul
giornale che poi viene parato dal fatto
di recente bisogno di happiness infatti
una notizia così non si sentiva da
insomma un bel po di tempo
betty ing grazie 1000 v alcuni da
giacomo ragazzi mentre io schiaccio il
pisello a nonno ciak con la mia band
sfavore consolino insomma web commenta
giacomo e next wine list e rampart la
donna che il casinò scusatemi non volevo
non volevo fare questa cosa però è
accaduta
mi dispiace avanti ma è una specie non è
vero mi dispiace mi scusi ho sbagliato
ho fatto non volevo fare questa mille
episodi e prisco fatto aver mai successo
di cadere sopra un tizio infatti non ho
ma questo si chiama massaggio
terapeutico per la schiena zio e te lo
faccio gratis e non è che di vita mia
però ok sin da rella al mcdonald
buongiorno le live action bar o cosa che
succede qua oh mio dio è vabbè e vabbè è
partita una roccia
nello spazio ragazzi allora questo non è
un range game
perché questo non è un rai cinema quindi
porca vacca no mannaia francesco thank
you so much for the town e jean master
marionette che somma spoleto nation è
già comunque come giorgio texani no
stavo dicendo non è non ha un browser
family e perché come più vi sono riporti
blog o quanta stima lo stai sarebbe
figlio per i nostri allora settimana lo
sta in realtà comprenderebbe solo i blog
perché alla fine gli old style cioè
primis che non è mai andato via
e i blog perché adesso rivideo sono
comunque io ho sempre avuto lo stesso
stile ragazzi miei non ho mai cambiato
quindi l'unica roba molto old style che
una volta facevo su sette video c4 erano
horror e uno e rapidi sabato non blog e
l'altro al gioco divertente però erano
quasi tutti horror è data al capitano le
settimane così quindi l'unica roba che
manca il blog che poi lo faccio ma non è
semplicemente il fa vi risponde quello
stai dicendo avrebbe senso ma avrebbe
senso riportarlo proprio generale sto
cazzo di mattone scusatevi questo un
canale che mi difende non volevo dire
cazzo voglio dire razzo razza qualcosa
che parte e va insomma nello spazio per
colonizzare gli altri pianeti creare
un'altra civiltà sperando che questa
civiltà non inventi un altro è più il se
andiamo avanti ragazzi ero molto qua
perfetto sono aveni che pian piano
miglioro perso solo un piede ma chi se
ne frega foot locker e via
in cambio le scarpe allora
se finisci livello chi tornava ragazzi
adesso non devo niente a non è che non è
non è forte knight barra fall guys dove
fare le vittorie però questa è pinguis
non ci prendiamo sul serio su happy with
per l'amor di dio
nel frattempo sta andando avanti con
salve mi scusi ok grazie mi avete dato
come premio una coppa al contrario ma va
benissimo
fa niente martina insomma prayer circus
l'incolumità della tastiera gloria
ragione effettivamente però non credo
che le preghiere riesca a salvare la mia
tastiera sarebbe si è già rotta sei o
sette volte semplicemente come i gatti
ha un sacco di vite quindi a posto
andrea techframe nation mirko pure ricky
web come giacomo grazie mille per la
telefonia un cioè in iii livello ai ciò
suo nonno ciak
ma cosa non c'è anche come pokémon
potemo jim o mio dio strade ai a tutto a
posto il mio pokemon e salvo non vedi
non conosciate impossibile farlo livello
però ci provo lo stesso die è come
giocare a pokemon e modalità difficile
quando va tutto bene pikachu grazie
mille
io pensavo che pagano per cento family
friendly ma ho capito niente beefcake
madonna torta di carne c'era scritto
però vabbè non vorrei un marshall non
vorrei fare a cazzotti con un mash up
della mia vita
ma ciò che volevo era gen ibaf x.com e
in peace comin nel senso che mi casca in
terra tutto bene tutto a posto
non tutto a posto ragazzi sadness
traction non è vero
autodistruzione ragazzi non è la mossa
più stupida di pokemon che esista che
ammazza al pokémon prove quando of the
fallen nation my brother ragazzi vi
ricordo che se volete supportarmi potete
fare una donazione cosa su frecciate
quali fianco poi sui pasti fax oppure
collabor abbonandovi coi vari perche vi
ricordo che questo mese ci sono i
griffin anteprima saranno ben porca
vacca mi ha fatto un culo così saranno
ben due
anche questo mese ci saranno due video
anteprima per gli abbonati come ogni
mese realtà sarebbe uno però visto che
non può da parte benevento 2 quando
capita lo faccio
attacca migrazione o cambiamo messo la
bici ragazzi perché mi mancava la la
destrezza con uno shock però purtroppo
serve fin troppo grazie mille
dell'elettore della torta di carne come
yes brothers perni volumi del gioco ma
arrivati a posto non dimenticato allora
adesso vedo se riesco a passare madonna
come rischiato però va bene tutto a
paganica con la beach più easy ko bella
favino piegata notifica non fa niente tu
sai che il pon fari e sempre diretta il
la domenica quindi non te ne frega anni
e tanti sebastian
grazie mille quindi è di valle faul e
donation brother the screw addio
mi sono cagato addosso ai cosa not want
to hold 18 buon tono bene era il meme di
una volta vescio da questo video
questo livello saltato
hai mai pensato di portare video su
reddit no gabry web come intesa come
l'erogazione della lavorazione otto anni
di epiche ma forse non ci arriviamo
speriamo a otto anni di happy feet
insomma potrebbe essere l'ultimo
episodio come no vediamo come si
comporta in questa live oh mio dio cosa
vedo ero ragazzino testare casi ma
proprio dovete stare calmi ma di un
calmo che non avete idea vi dovete fare
una tisana eindhoven up ma porca vacca
così profit dal terreno
comunque questi livelli qua ragazzi sono
quelli per chi si è connesso adesso sono
i livelli più giocati nella storia di
apple e quindi come speciale facendo ste
tre ore mi sono pagato in mano siamo
all'inizio e farò queste tre ore sui
livelli più giocati nella storia di
tutto british quindi dio mio mi è morto
luke fa niente anzi meglio
oddio cosa vedo cos'era
ma se le noirmont computer chi se ne
frega non importava arrivare vivi
anche perché ce ne sono quattro di
livelli le sarte inserita new level li
facciamo tutti sto provando a vedere
quanto riesco ad arrivare lontano con
livelli top perché poi alla fine faremo
dopo le 3 ore faremo una conta di tutti
i livelli che abbiamo fatto e vediamo
quanti sono riuscito a farle in tre ore
una sorta di challenge se avete una
giornata da buttare potete fare la
stessa cosa vedere se riuscite a fare
come me anche se alcuni visto schipa
nguini non vale nemmeno vedo che
comunque un occhio di riguardo per gli
occhi cielo sempre ho guardato di miglio
porca vacca voi quasi per sul sellino
fighissimo black toniolo 4w giorgio kat
singer a posto tutto ok ragazzi
ok simone grazie a donation tutto bene
laga don't worry infatti è una allora
siamo calmi click e kick un cazzo perché
lo fa chi con una sega doveva tornare
indietro
no c'è look spappolato indie 2 vado
cazzeggiare è una è una e una censura
ragazzi non so se hai notato ho perso un
braccio random cosa clicco tu madre o
che ne so io quindi russa ave certo
ovvio mi sembra che la la mia seconda
opzione questa va bene o mio dio
minchia se me la sono vista brutta tutto
a posto ragazzi kamau frency artiste
giacomo prova del grazie mille se
riuscissi a ho giocato a tetris un bel
po di anni e secondo me sta roba qua a
sorpassare quindi vai avanti ip per il
culo ok io ho fatto anche secondo
livello niente male
ci sono quattro livelli non lo questo si
è fatto uno sfatti pazzesco come fai a
fare quattro livelli in uno che palle
veramente la rottura già farne uno mazza
comunque non resiste apparati di filse
il rogo guidi do magic official saluti
da paolo pomponi na roba il tuo archivio
vivente
browser fendi grazie mille il bondi do è
certo è certo questa questa è la storia
un giorno
un giorno i libri di storia canteranno
delle gesta e delle miracolose avventure
mela bologna leggendari avventure del
favi e del di do magic e di come tutto
ebbe inizio
signori è del set a parte il parte il
fatto che mi cadono i pali in faccia non
fa niente ha tra l'altro la volevo dirvi
ho giocato recentemente che non aveva
ancora giocato ad huntington che voi
tutti avete detto porta lo portano
portano portalo quando era uscito avrei
dovuto portarlo ai tempi non l'ho mai
portato
uno dei ma perché mi sismi ma cosa fai
oggi è più il contro di me
vuoi rem armi contro perché il
duecentesimo episodio invece di volermi
bene nessuno ti ha mai giocato per così
tanto si sono tutte le palle tutte le
palle prima invece mi ringrazi così io
veramente non lo so comunque a pierre
guarita grazie per la donazione
scusatemi che non avevo letto o
scrostato la barca no niente stavo
dicendo quindi non mi remare contro
almeno per favore che già è difficile
ok ok non è vero shaun boss da battere
senza la ruota o schiacciato luke ma è
tutto bene tutto a posto
click a devono devo colpi oddio dopo il
pisco con le rocce fingo o lo colpiscono
la botta dio dio dio dio dio dio dio
meno male con la roccia che ora che ho
la ruota monca fam
oddio ho vinto con la ruota monca ragas
non sono io il miglior giocatore di è
più se la vita non lo so
level frico blair è let's go with the
level for the last one ragazzi gabriele
qualche minto giacomo mickey è the king
rail internet freedom nation e saluto a
tristan
insomma ci lauren ragazzi da voi che
seguite primis sparatemi una teca
seguite i miei video su mtv sparatemi un
anno regata per passare questa porta
dorata hai bisogno di collezionare tutti
i numeri dei livelli 1 e 3 select the
number with your mouth
non ho capito a si vede che c'era un
codice da segnarsi rifare tutti e tre
allora bull e t gold wing del golf
ascolto un'ex cava o cinque anni 24 anni
58 anni non ero banco nato io che dice
cinque anni io da il 1715 il codice 195
va bene vediamo se funziona
voglio dire se per una volta mi siete
stati u tin che succeda spesso però
vediamo proprio al curiosità volesse
lasciatemi mi mia seconda promo un
tentativo solo 195 no 196 all etto anche
quello sei anni madonna raga pazzesca
sta roba da medioevo effettivamente il
favi medievale me lo ricordo quando
[Musica]
veniva accusato di stregoneria per aver
portato ai pigs troppo presto dunque non
va raga 795 che la proviamo quello sono
ma quello mi cambio da tutti se ne
fregano era per curiosità presenti a
sfruttare la chat allora il 7 sta qua
795 thank you ragazzi ma grazie ma
funzionato veramente lei air force che a
livello di merda
vediamo se riusciamo a farlo recente
bellissima è più in là i ragazzi non
c'era da da una vita almeno credo da
almeno sette no l'avevo fatto l'anno
scorso in realtà avevo fatto però l'ho
fatto veramente poche volte in live
ragazzi a chi ce l'avrà fatto tre volte
compresa questa la prima volta era per
lo speciale centesimo episodio un'ora di
happy vis l'altra volta l'ho fatto la
che palle o mano e difficile l'altra
volta l'ultima volta l'ho fatto l'anno
scorso e questa volta ben 53 ore di epic
poi faremo foglianise ragazzi protetto
però insomma non perdete vista
appuntamento con lucky storia che è
molto importante
insomma se vi siete visti questi il
duecentesimo non perdetevelo in diretta
chiamate tutti la nonna l'amico il
cugino slow slow lo dice a tua sorella
io vado veloce quanto voglio
logan
non ti incazzare però cioè puoi dire
tutto nel senso con calma calma proprio
tranquillo
gabrielle ha chius commerciale donation
avevo le serate a falle e rocket beh
diciamo che aprire grazie alla donazione
faremo un utente qualsiasi ora eccomi da
gioco io in generale le lay pomeridiane
tipo questo tipo queste le utilizzo per
fare per giocare con voi tranne questa
perché giocherò adepti vis e afol guys
con domandare chiaro che sono così si
chiama le la grossa qua se ne frega bene
tra di queste che utilizzerò la
utilizzano per giocare eyed peas
applegate dal mese prossimo farò anche
rocket o gta insomma con voi pomeriggio
corri corri mannaia oddio dio dio dio
tutto a posto ragazzi ex succede quando
vai nel deserto che tutti dei vermi ti
spuntino è tutto a posto tutto bene va
bene è passato rocco di qua non cogliete
la città
vi prego molto bene andiamo avanti find
some pain trova qualcosa ma cosa vuoi
che ribatte grazie mille per il super
sic mi riempie d'orgoglio che sei
che utilizzi spesso i super ticket to
che ribatte lo sai grazie mille a la
spalla non trova la spada nella roccia
luke lancia gliela apple la spada nel
granchio e normale che escano delle
chele dal deserto tutto bene però vabbè
livelli più usati al mondo un utente
qualsiasi grazie anche per la donazione
caro ho preso il verme fratelli e dove
anna così che doveva ok non è vero c'è
un cobra dopo il pit l'incasso rischiato
tantissimo colpisci non si si come
pisano 2 tutto a posto colpisco
[Musica]
beh ho colpito non si fa nulla
forse devo andare molto più indietro
anzi oddio mica sono rischiato vai da
ucciso lo anche investito fuller altri
anche il loot finale vediamo o bravo per
la giocata a questi 26 anni di happy
meals bene questo non ringraziamento che
non avrei mai sperato di ricevere tra
sbarre tutti aspettavano l'episodio 200
tipo tutti ma ragazzi anch'io
effettivamente volevo vedere se la mia
vita si sarebbe spinta tanto la risposta
è sì e non saranno neanche gli ultimi
però il duecentesimo è uno di quei mas
che va visto kodu in the crowd quello
che non ho fatto prima ragazzi e non
solo a farlo livello molto corto ma
ragazzi tutti sti livelli avete presente
più o meno quanto ci metto a fare un
video di happy wheels ecco c'è qualche
quanti livelli fascino video normali
epis ne faccio una decina ok di più 10
15 grazie stefano bradoni sera quando ho
fatti quattro ok e vedete
vabbè che uno a quattro livelli lento
meno fatti 778 quindi ci ho messo per
adesso 27 minuti questo vi fa capire
quanto ci mettono registare un episodio
è più su un oretta perché siamo a metà
di un normale episodio
ok questo mi sto dicendo gulin 8 teche
sono marci forte a bonazzo nega lo godo
in the gods wins the scenes per chi non
lo conoscesse ragazzi è uno dei creatori
più famosi livelli su happy visto che fa
dei livelli pazzeschi vedete che roba da
un gioco a parte addirittura ci sono due
tasti shift per sprintare anno per
incornare la gente o che va bene mi
piace e l'altro per saltare ok
se non mia se non mi attivasse i tasti
permanenti di windows ma quella m storia
in corno io non ti don't worry spacco
tutto me ne sbatto non posso spaccare il
fragile eppure gestito fragile ma teatro
perché staff a un verso stranissimo sta
casa l'ariete che cacchio è sta roba qua
tutto a posto
ciao ragazzi dove devo andare a devo
spingere la roba per salire di sopra
scusami non ci gioco spetta non gioco a
livelli così intelligenti di happy with
spesso ma posso anche incornare full
quindi non smettere ma di incornare va
bene questo è un attimo guarda che se
non ti fai i capelli non ve li na sega
sembri un emo guardato la porto ahimè
testate sulle robe e si va a comandare
giacomo grazie alla donazione la live
non dovesse di 5 ore e ti prego leggi la
descrizione vediamo se riesco a attivare
stadio corre nuova ragazzi livelli sono
fatti benissimo benissimo sa che devo
ottenere
lo stesso rumore sentito un rumore che
non mi è piaciuto per niente ok tutto
bene anno dopo portare sulla scatola
vado inizio nella mia vita fa schifo
questo lavoro fatto e infatti questo qua
ragazzi avevo già fatto una volta
infatti gli ho detto che lo conoscevo
già perché alcuni livelli di questo è
che riveli più giornata di a le ho fatti
perché ogni tanto io in questi 200
episodi mi mettevo a giocare anche la
classifica mondiale che è quella che sto
facendo in questo speciale di tre ore
rivogliamo farinate freddy's ragazzi lo
porterò per uscire a quello nuovo
per forza ve lo prometto questo don tuoi
live view tanto dura non sa questo
livello come ok è un enigma della
madonna ma mi ha preso per una persona
intelligente eccolo qua non ho neanche
capito cos'è successo ma fa niente
ma adesso devo fare un bel pò di madonna
ma quanto quanto quanto è quanto sto
livello è fatto bene ben pensato questo
giro sta fare mi devo mettere qua sopra
sicuro
insomma devo girare sta roba qua a
manetta
eccoci
niall cacchio prova gira dall'altra
parte si dai dai dai che ce la fa ce la
faccio no ma già il pene di fermare non
ti fermare ti fa fare
non ci credo
maledizione è difficilissimo perché
parte devo andare gadea destra sia
uguale penso cristiane vuoi comité già
con my brother grazie mille
devi prendere solo più spinta si fa il
perfetto vadano a devo anche sblocca ma
basta co sti tasti permanenti ma che ca
che cosa servono i tasti permanenti che
non ho mai capito a parte romperti le
palle a manetta e non l'ho mai capita
sta roba
mi sa che devo pure fare in fretta raga
prima che la porta sism in chi c'è dopo
una roba infattibile io giro a manetta e
poi devo girare l'altro a manetta sono
fine ormai
ok ma gira gira gira gira gira gira gira
gira gira gira gira perfetto ma tom non
è vero
e impossibile ci vuole un tempismo
pazzesco bella ragazza omber simone
grazie mille si ok ci prova di nuovo
ragazzi michele è veramente un casino ok
stavolta è impossibile fatto tutto il
giro perfetto madonna meno male perché
lo caduto
raga pasta quanto su quella sta roba c'è
un uccello e quindi verde walsh point
dottor aiuta a è partito un trenino qui
devo seguire il trenino fino all
indietro poiché è successo ma treno va
abbattuto indietro
oppure dovevo beccare il piccione no
perché non ci torno e di suo è un
incacchia secondo me devono seguire non
ho capito se devo seguire il 3 rosso e
dovevo beccare il piccione
non penso che mi faccia tornare indietro
con a bordo chissenefrega vai al tuo
elaborazione a schermo ragazzi non
funzionano perché il discorso delle
belle degli alert decidono quelli del
programma che sto utilizzando quando
farlo funzionare quando non
produttivamente stanno avendo problemi
quindi li leggo senza che compaiono a
schermo
penso che lo fixer anno nelle prossime
settimane la prova bene io ve la leggo
uguale è più bello a schermo certo come
ho sempre fatto
però quando la fixer anno vale next ko
perfetto perfetto oddio va benissimo
va benissimo
pagano no
comunque non ho mai fatto un livello di
fb scuola bmx non è verranno fatti un
sacco ma mai della classifica mondiale
credo quindi la cosa mi mi alletta se
non avessi sbattuto contro un muro e 300
all'ora ma quello è un must die quando
vai in vicino state sempre attenti una
nota invece i ragazzi usati freni che io
non posso fare a quanto pare loro the
look mi ha tenuto fermo ma fa niente
devo prendere abbastanza slancio però
che se non faccio niente
ecco esatto vivi che vivono non
sopravvivere quanto devo andare veloce
spiega se vado lento e troppo lento se
vado veloce mischia mi spiace decisivi
quanto tempo sarà il ai ragazzi l'ho
scritto la descrizione fidatevi che
leggerla non è mai male ok che stavolta
però non perdere anche uk per quanto non
mi serve a niente
perfetto se come stavolta quella buona
laga
non so arrivato velocissimo perché io
parlo perché io ancora non ho capito
come si sta zitti
dopo anni che parlo io parlo ma cosa
parlo mio dio
prova a fare il giro totale nel coso con
senza luke non riesco a lanciarlo non me
l'ha neanche adesso
ok adesso ha fatto adesso veramente
lentissimo si circolo che culo finale ci
sono cascato sopra sono ciao se non
parli non saresti quasi a 6 milioni ma
secondo me sì secondo me sarei a 6
milioni di chi comunque ragazzi portati
tutti ed iscriversi anche la nonna
perché troppo arriviamo a 6 milioni la
gara e mega mega perché è importante
fate tutti i parti di questo record
clamoroso dei 6 milioni non vorreste
mica essere fuori quando raggiungerò
perché lo raggiungiamo tutti i
chipleader quindi iscrivetevi
mi raccomando mi raccomando lo questo
rock kings con nonno ciak tra l'altro
non ho mai fatto
hanno forse avevo fatto una volta un
drop di condono ciak però è rarissimo
per gli hawks ying sono roba di steve
heide per lo speciale certo ma non posso
spoilerarvi nulla
yes perfetto è andata anche bene secondo
me è molto più bravo lancia che gestiva
farei il rock swing tutto ciò bravissimo
anche perché non lo shock è molto pi
conico di steve di el di volevo dire
scusate mi sono confuso
però non ho mai fatto non so per quale
motivo le stime cioè impossible enti cia
se premuto europe singh ma non sa che
non ha mai avuto un gas
ogni tanto uso quando non si voglia di
usare gli altri in poche parole ho
sputato non solo visto che si è visto lo
dico io ho sputato sulla tastiera tanto
yes
non è vero sono ancora in piedi musso
come non è possibile
madonna madonna come mi sono salvato che
culo
meno male che la fortuna vista sì mi
assiste in questo episodio perché
essendo il 200esimo giocavano giocavamo
più di dieci anni fa sulla playstation 3
spesso poi leggo addio
raga pensate che forse mi salvo
cosa sto vedendo cosa vedo la cosa più
trash del mondo malati o no ma il
partito il braccio peccato perché melo
salvato se esserne un numero salvato
l'avevo fatta giocatrice di maso queste
c'è il 3 soprattutto cod
ti ho appena visto ero io vi naruto
contenti per gli anni qui su youtube
grazie mille caro
non mi ricordo mannaia accordi giocavamo
più di dieci anni fa famelico da dieci
anni fa
cosa c'era dieci anni raccoglie a non
forse sì io ti ho mad o forse vi ricordo
mi ricordo di un nome del genere mamma
mia che cosa ha deviato fuori sì forse
mi ricordo caro
non so se te lo sei inventato non penso
ti mando un bacio stellare frate grazie
mille
grazie mille mi ricordo a proprio
offuscato la memoria ma poi cosa mi
ricordo grande sì grazie mila il
supporto comunque grazie mille di aver
fatto ricordare che ho avuto un'infanzia
insomma no sì sì vero vero vero comunque
fighissimo fuga spero di non riuscire a
morire no perché il gerrei io sono
famoso per salvare i suoi primis nelle
situazioni dove in realtà dovrei essere
morto e c'era veramente riuscito per un
niente ma suo livello la finito ragazzi
cervelo va assolutamente fini questo è
veramente spettacolare e fatto bene il
rock singh ci credo che uno dei livelli
più votati di erbe spesso sia credo sia
addirittura il primo rock swing perché
questi questo non livelli fatti anni fa
per finire in quella classifica non
tutti ovviamente
e quindi credo sia uno dei primi rock
singh se non è il primo comunque è
comunque il più bello senza ombre questo
è il più bel rob si è mai fatto qualche
roba che design di livello cielo sopra
ha fatto little nightmare sono affatto
rock swing marche tra coni sei più forte
donation my brother award
thank you so much per elaborazione
bello bello sta corda del lecce caso dei
colli del lecce dove si invita di non
seguo il calcio ragazzi però yes
[Musica]
proprio lui va bene a ma in live ragazzi
un bacio a chi se n'è accorto adesso
camon ops è corsa giusta ecco corsa a
ostacoli non credo sia perché è uno dei
livelli di tipi di livello più famoso
sulle piste ragazzi non ho mai fatte
così tante di corsa ad ostacoli ora che
ci penso perché mi hanno fatto tutte
cagare adesso vi faccio vedere il motivo
ve lo faccio vedere entrambi un secondo
lo vedete tra un secondo vedetevi don't
worry be solo spiego adesso vi spiego
perché mi fanno cagare e da un attimo
ecco per questo per questo motivo mi
fanno perché doveva martoriare il nonno
ma poi io non decido io non ho deciso
niente l'ha fatto lui io non ho deciso
di martoriare nulla e sono loro che gli
chiede scelgono i livelli con prima ed
altro non sa che non capisco perché nei
livelli sia per quello più bistrattato
poverino mai capito perché per ora
andiamo avanti con schivato abbassando
la testa
tranquilli ragazzi casconi copre
facciamo finta di niente
non è vero sono stati dietro tutto bene
tutto bene tutto bene come passo di qua
spiegami come fa come faccio come posso
ok bello un gioco di merda con questo
gioco fa veramente cag a cagare
come ho fatto arrivare a 200 mila sto
scherzando ragazzi che sono detto thomas
youtube con video giacomo margotta 25
grazie mille tesoro un bacio gigante
permette al supporto grazie sorella o
sisters emiliano gorelli insomma le
donne shawn e chiusi nel carnet si ok ok
adesso adesso è tutto chiaro
adesso è tutto chiaro my brother
grazie mille di esserti fatto rivedere
frate vorrei fare una reunion
però tu ci sei e sappi che almeno noi ci
siamo stretti la mano a distanza ma
siamo di stretta dieci anni di
differenza porca vacca se il tempo passa
ragazzi io quando il primo di fare
youtube
adesso vi racconto questa volta prima di
fare youtube
no no ma soli vedova finito cioè adesso
va bene tutto adesso porta di una vacca
piuttosto mi spacco la tastiera per ora
finito quando tutto è iniziato nel senso
che la spiego stavano da vari come sedi
in tanti io la mia carriera su internet
cominciata con
call of duty perché viste io ho giocato
tantissimo sulla black jack avo
tantissimo sulla playstation al call of
duty il 4 poi a modern warfare 2
quando erano usciti ma tanto ci faccio
un sacco di video poi scusatemi
scusatemi prima ancora giocavo porco il
demonio morto giocavo per i cavoli miei
cercare di spiegarmi lo abbia mantenendo
la calma è veramente difficile
giocavo per i cavoli miei giocava nei
clan
insomma ero attivo nei vari forum che
esistevano dove si parlava di call of
duty dove si organizzavano le le clan
wars le guerre tra tra chi giocava a
call of duty e quindi ero new clan
chiamato nsx che era new soul di air
extreme ma che ve lo so dire tanto c'era
anche nicky c'era anche nicky in questo
clan bellissimo poi sono diventato
moderatore di un sito sia di ricci
planet ai tempi era un moderatore di
questo sito che anche forum scusate che
andava tantissimo dove si parlava
insomma se per i call of duty lo del
genere
e della spettacolare anche quello e poi
da lì sono nati vari commenti su youtube
e il mio canale che ai tempi era diviso
tra manic box e ai legamenti
[Musica]
minchia di barili ok è visto perché
spiega le cose tranquillamente poi di
tanto ciò se scatti d'ira andavano
all'inizio cioè tu particolare youtube
che fai una visualizzazione noi
partivamo che avevamo un centinaio
perché questo perché cos'è un frullatore
sto coso ok giocatori scorretti che è
sta roba
ah ok a una macchina del tempo cinese
stavo dicendo ma non è che devo
diventare tarzan adesso vado a letto
dicevo quindi io milingo si trovano già
una scintu centinaia di visualizzazioni
perché questa equipe quando ha fame in
generale quando amiamo le grigliate
quest'anno cioè non dinosauro se l'è
mangiata nichele griglia
io invece faccio lo spiedo e quindi
quando facciamo i primissimi video su
youtube di parole 2011 sono stato e sono
stato bloccato in questa niente lo fa
niente la gente che ci seguiva
all'inizio erano quelli che ci
conoscevano presto forum erano gli
utenti sto comunque e poi da lì iniziato
di share e gaming poi aperto fa
ricettivo e oggi siamo qua 200 episodi e
quindi da delle clouds di call of duty
siamo arrivati a 200 episodi di happy
with come è successo tutto questo dio
mio
sono vivo sono vivo a posto mi ha solo
dato una pedata fortissimo ma tutta
tutto normale doventato l'occidente a
qua dentro lui lovato trovato dio che
plot twist sono finiti in una caverna ma
che livello pazzesco che quei ragazzi
fatto benissimo ha fatto benissimo
land kier ok ok ad evo devo alzare le
gambe non ho le gambe come l'alzo non ce
l'ho
ok a posto grafiche e non me lo grappa e
non velo club sa se sei stupido che hai
fatto livello stupido usando i crabs
space triceratops tail non lo posso
campare altri ce robot state of top top
of the pops perché non ci arrivo però
posso gravare volendo il corpo vediamo
se hai fatto le cose anche di core
non ci posso arrivare perché non avevo
le gambe non hai pensato a me che non ce
l'avevo che non ci arrivava lì ma niall
bigolo ma perché le vorrei dare un
triceratopo non potete farmi venire
livello e basta come che fa entrò alla
fine pronome però a prescindere vuoi
provare a gravare con grappa lettere
ok pazzesco
yuri chechi che chi yuri jury chechi no
con gli anelli no oddio
sì ce l'ho fatta
non è vero solo smosso ho capito ma c'è
mica è fatto solo la coda grappa vi
lennon tutto il resto di solito fanno
tutto il resto grabar forse già guarda
che comunque semplice impegno ci arriva
e profano un salto di così guardate che
se riesco a fare sta roba ragazzi trofeo
volevo fare un salto aspetta che forse
forse ci riesco
il centre volando ma forse ci riesco
di secondi ma circa barbu next tanto
alla fine speed bridge la velocità sul
ponte vediamo che succede ma aspetta che
stavo leggendo delle donazioni come
leggo posto livello comunque ragazzi non
avete idea di quante volte su happy le
situazioni del genere io le taglio e poi
li faccio il livello qua non posso
perché sa mai live sono state iori sul
livello ma tante tante volte vi capita
di stare sei ore su un livello di è più
visto per poi tagliare in un normale e
video quindi questo significa fare lo
youtube e ragazzi portare
intrattenimento e tagliare tutte le
parti non necessarie che alle volte
richiedono minuti alle volte anche raro
però anche ore di registrazione a vuoto
perché magari vi raggiungere un punto e
partire da lì col video ok ora è solo
quando perdi salvataggi nathan
meraviglioso allora giggs matthews for
the well thank you for the well come in
the giacomo di gamer youtube grazie
mille dal dalla hbo nazione grazie
ragazzi che dei tempi quelli di code
fratello che bei tempi quando era bravo
quando four nights era non c'era era non
c'era non è vero non è che porta in sé
rovinato niente anzi io stimo quelli che
sono riusciti a portare forte così in
alto
sto dicendo che a me personalmente non
fa impazzire ma io ho un gusto
c'è poi gli altri hanno un altro quindi
non c'entra niente giocate ed i verdi
importante e divertirvi non come sto
facendo io insomma io sto solo tirando
pugni a questa povera tastiera da
insomma almeno 200 episodi porterai
anche per un braccio e light of the
archive grazie john cena menez
grazie anche per aver star minchia di
polemiche la buccia di banana mi ha
veramente bloccato il tra il percorso
spiega mi tutte le partite e vabbè vabbè
vabbè ma ragazzi e tutto partito da una
buccia di banana va bene stavo dicendo
hai nominato un bel un bel episodi
penombra che nessuno conosce perché è
una moda in realtà non era ufficiale
credo dario è mattia o eccomi de giacomo
fratelli miei grazie mille
lo porterò secondo me sì secondo me lo
dico perché attualmente non in
programmazione ma lo portò di coda
ragazzi se volete supportare il sole
donation con la super certo quali fianco
oppure laborazione qua sotto potete
abbonarvi al canale oppure i super
sticker potete utilizzare sempre se
volete che sono negativi grazie mille
non ho fatto in tempo a leggere matip
ripiglio non tuorli bomber 18 11 grazie
mille tanto sono in ascensore
mi saluti mi chiama arianna no scherzo
cioè penso che variano un bacio voglio
bene
c'è un topolino o livello infatti non mi
è nuovo questo chissà quale da qualche
anno quanti anni fa l'ho fatto ma non
buttare di sotto anno dollari troppo
cari
mattia welcome in de giacomo fratello
mio grazie mille del supporto grazie fra
te e tutto ok tutto bene don't worry
tutto a posto
e vabbè mi chiama state calmi che
succede
stavo guardando dei video veramente
brutti 20 posso skippare la in tono
stiamo due ore qua non si fa mai
ne approfitto per bene comunque sono
contento ragazzi che abbiate seguito 200
episodi è qui se tanta roba neanche io
li ho seguiti che io ho fatti
figuriamoci
io sono veramente curioso di sapere se
qualcuno tra di voi c'è veramente dal
primo se qualcuno tra di voi c'è
veramente l'altri mollo scriva dal primo
dire che sono sette anni e mezzo se
c'era quando è uscito il primo ragazzi
sarà un pieno di yo yo yo yo yo quindi
non ci crederò mai ma se qualcuno lo
dice veramente non ti posso vedere
perchè sarai sommerso dagli altri io ma
io ti sono vicino grazie come sono
vicino agli altri altare garda che mr
però pensa che achievement stata il
primo però oggi voi avete un altro
ciments siete all'ultimo no scherzo
siete al duecentesimo che comunque
vederli in live è tanta roba se non è
visto che sono stati 200 cacchio di
episodi che succedono tutti i giorni
allora se non avessi mai perché comunque
i hoepli o lo dismesso dopo un po sono
avessi mai dismesso happy wheels a
quest'ora saremmo al hader you are
c'era un po a loro visto video è inutile
che fai finta di te l'ho visto questo
quale avevo già fatto perché ho fatto
questa con tartina l'aveva chiamata è
più il se nel passato una roba del
genere cosa vedo mi hanno sparato fa
niente non ho seguito la trama non che
mi interessi
tu sei stato liberazione di moltissimi
youtuber che portava videogiochi grazie
caro
grazie grazie mille se non avete
rischiato altra gente visto che altra
gente è ispirato me quindi è un ispira è
un'ispirazione inception un inci spira
un inspira cep soluzione quella roba lì
sono sceso da un dinosauro tutto nella
norma tanto si chiama devils quindi non
ci sia niente claudio finestrone decreto
nation e francesco passetti welcome in
de giacomo mcbride o siamo ritornati
alla buccia di banana e il mondo si
ripete come the net suo film a prima
di lei standby christopher nolan va bene
grazie
next livello ragazzi le dollari trip un
viaggio da 1.000 dollari
devi porti
io ci sono al 2016 said life ma dal 2006
lo zio cosa succede skip skip anno
abbiamo bisogno di te per testare la
nostra medicina si mostro porcellino
d'india per un paio d'ore e prenditi
mille dollari
sapendo di aver fatto qualcosa di bello
nato inutile di vita ok qualcosa non va
bene cos'è
non me ne frega niente basta che mi
danno i media nei miei soldi proceda
signore va bene mi danno la medicina va
bene e mi metto a mi stanno dando la
medicina va bene sono troppo sexy mi
saluti certo che i rosa ci credo anche
gli hanno iniettato ok tutto bene tutto
a posto tutto meraviglioso se sapremo
mettevo questa è una copertina
allora insomma penso insomma
io sto giocando a un gioco normalissimo
quindi non fatevi scrupoli a dire che
cosa pensate di questo gioco io l'ho già
detto
quindi c'è un cervello nella padella
ok ma che fino a questo livello ragazzi
parte gli scherzi o addio by yoox
rendimi fiero non sono anche come non la
devo farlo questo ragazzo scusatemi lo
schifo lo schifo ma lo facciamo perché è
veramente troppo bello come si vede
troppo bello quindi va bene è un livello
fatto veramente bene questa è la prima
volta che mi capita un livello fosse uno
dei più belle che io abbia mai fatto sua
piece a livello di grafica minchiata la
pagina perfetto non so per quanto tengo
schermo intero per una questione di
family friendly vita quello
non so neanche se si dice family friends
ita ma facciamo finta di cisco
madonna sono rischiato fa niente non
premere va bene però siamo con tutta la
vita se non lo premo vorrei non
prenderlo ma ce lo stiamo qua tutta la
vita anzi e non tre ore di tempo non sei
anni lui la madonna ho fatto fatto bene
quanto fatto bene quanto fatto appunto
quanto fatto perché io confermerei
magari ecco niente non è peccato io che
volevo gravare easy ma se n'è andato
proprio cosa succede oddio come cavia e
va beh no una boss fight not dead versus
doc
spiegami se questo è il boss finale di è
più visti melo prima metto qua va bene
che dovevamo d'oggi
ok e madonna che botta logge da oggi ad
oggi ad oggi da oggi di nuovo e sono
foto sono un fenomeno sono bravo scuola
i giochi di ex post i livelli sono bravo
anche a chi ha fatto bene il suo livelli
penso sia il boss finale praticamente
dovrà resistere finché non finisce il
timer mining va bene ciao favicon i
porti geometri dash e molto bene su un
calo ovunque
ok ho ricevuto i miei soldi
dopo tutto sto casino ci sono un po di
effetti collaterali l'aggressività
povero dottore texture plaining ma di
cosa stiamo parlando
ma amico mio cosa ti fumi spiegamelo
anziano vedovo ryan certo che ti saluto
grazie mille che mi seguite 100k e
filippo per un thank you for education
ragazzi dai mansion prima dei match
vediamo che chi esce fuori skip me ne
frega niente di tutto sto bordello
ragazzi faccio l'ultimo e vado tre
secondi in pausa faccio tre secondi di
pausa vado solo a pisciare ogni ora
faccio tre secondi di pausa per una
pisciatina a loro e poi torno però
sempre così perché devo un sacco di
acqua durante la i ragazzi viene andare
al bagno
siccome devo fare queste cinque ore di
fila e bene che almeno tre minuti per il
bagno gli utili non è anche data 1 le
basta però li utilizzo così dimensione 4
ma ce l'avete veramente con la
preistoria mi chiama di quasi ucciso si
poteva farmi veramente ma potevo
rimanere offeso cosa è successo
ok buffo zoom tanto sono incastrato con
la ok per passarci sopra si detto di sì
però non ci arrivo perché le mie ruote
fanno schifo non ci sono la 5 dal primo
episodio ma ti seguo da cinque anni
grazie jessica grazie gara da prezzo a
preceder di alien challenge view a volte
del red
r us va bene ok e la madonna in caio ken
quello ovunque tutto a posto raga finché
gli alieni mimì sfilano così è tutto ok
don't worry write
aliens che che deal with you anymore it
will self destruct stecco step back va
bene più vecchio di lei
ap rosso che livello è ragazzi questo
dimension five giocare qua sotto
entriamo qui si rivelino le ho mai fatti
la che è fatto veramente bene
sono i migliori mai visti su epiche se
posso fare dimensione insieme basta
quante dimensioni hai fatto rimbalzare
sui funghi è sempre stata la mia
passione comunque in tutti i livelli il
padre uk è veramente fatto io non volevo
dire altro ma ok allo schiacciare
sull'uomo stato ridotto odori dare
perché hai perso fluviali quintegia sono
cascato dimension seven aid aids sono
sono in un barattolo oddio sono cascato
in una pezza sono morto credo a nonno è
morto solo luke va bene va bene tutto a
posto tutto tutto a posto tutto lieto
fine ma la dimensione 10 la decina
dimensione e dove tutto quello che è
possibile immaginare è stato coperto
legge quindi non possiamo immaginare e
pd così dobbiamo prima ci fa però vedo
dietro un bel minecraft lockout side
comunque ragazzi i fasti livelli
veramente fatto e se la stessa persona
dall'altro è normale
alimenti ma che strano però vabbè vabbè
ai ragazzi piscio arrivo tre secondi di
pausa al toro
continuiamo con questa mega escalation
dei migliori episodi di the migliori
livelli di happy feet in queste tre ore
epiche poi ci saranno a seguire due ore
di faul guys come le università vado e
torno qua secolo arrivo
back to the number one happy è nata e il
duecentesimo però a livello di epicità
ciao ragazzi il termine dato che fa un
caldo quad e voi non sapete quanto fa
che fa caldo dentro quanto faccia caldo
dentro il mio studio però effettivamente
in estate è possibile vesco sono tornati
cotonati cari allora dài nation
l'abbiamo fatto
the seas gene haters the next one dove
siamo
non lo so sick di melo tempo e lo del
mare di slide e io ne ho un diffuso vaio
sale desidero ok c'è un apocalisse devo
far fuori un leader che devo seguirlo
per far fuori i leader va bene ok finita
perché ogni tanto mi sismica che non mi
via il tasto mi fa svecchiare la pagina
che ha posto l'ex papeete che fare
donation mai però dal lessico dio
saltato tutto con fuori don't worry
ragazzi be happy sono morto
non so come anno dove cadde risorse
effettivamente space barthus keep the
conversation less coop queste serre i
ragazzi forse perché non devo andare
troppo veloce lorenzo giornetti teche
sono le donne a quest'ora un ponte ok
iscriverla y
oddio what was that non lo so si ei no
aidia e per i vermi anche prima c'era
uno capitò dio dio
teniamoci calmiamoci tutto bene
usciamo dalla caverna not so se kakà o
dio
e vabbè vabbè
sono stato un fenomeno e non è mica
bello
non è un ragazzo tutto a posto tutto a
posto tutto a posto tutto ok tutto come
non detto farmi arrivare un bel
traguardo famiglie che ho finito sono
stato fortissimo non credo perché durano
sempre tanto si livelli però massima
attenzione lo colpisco perfetto tutto
tutto tutto le quadre o dio via via via
via via perfetto la mano è quindi stanno
succedendo cose veramente strana ragazzi
non fate domande dei gay
tutto bene tutto a posto
don't worry lo capisco come mai
credo che si livelli siamo tutti fatti
fatality cotone russe sono affatto i
livelli sono i primi tre livelli più
belli del mondo molti sono fatti alle
stesse persone perché qui ha talento per
fare dei dei livelli in genere ne fa
tanti fatti lavori conosciuto l'anno
stampa dallo stesso che livello pazzesco
dalle rose amazing sarebbe fen tech
insomma sto portinente unesco
you are here home decision haters mister
fatality va bene complimenti helicopter
home page
manager sono cascato addosso tutto bene
ragazzi
e vabbè lo so anche sparare i missili
raga don't worry
e le coste europei e gli ho sparato
game over a devo sbagli più misti ok va
bene sono cagato addosso
aiuto non mi ha colpito perché ho troppo
avanti molto bene
non ho finiti lì però lo spaccato vale
come
livello allegro non ho fatto questo e
molto era molto gt e balconi terror ma
do uno dei miei preferiti raga uno dei
miei preferiti a parte il fatto che se
tu vai qua e mister egg c'è questo qua
che si incastrano il tavolo tutto bene
tutto a posto poi questo tutta ricevendo
però balconi terra per niente tu devi
sopravvivere l'asta caduta non emettere
ci sono un sacco di balconi
il che è veramente figo perché non sai
neanche tu come sopravvivere perché
effettivamente tali da otto chilometri
normalmente non potresti sopravvivere ma
non si sa per quale motivo riesci c'è
dato sapere
66 anni va bene non c'è la vittoria in
realtà è credo che non ci sia vita forse
di variare proprio totalmente intatto
alla fine può essere ok ok ok ho dato
una testata veliche e contempo come se
sti balconi non riuscissero ucciderti
perché tiri testate fortissime e non ti
fai assolutamente nulla ecco
madonna è disastro problema è che non lo
sa che veramente la persona meno
indicata per fare il suo livello proprio
la meno indicata completamente non può
fare perché non ci passa spesso ci
arrivo no se non c'era lo stendino ci
arrivavo
a
quest'altro quello che aveva un fucile a
pompa per ma per quale motivo ma porca
la [ __ ] che è veramente difficile
fare balconi terro ragazzina di uno dei
preferiti ma è veramente un cane è
sempre stato un casino e può in realtà
io credo di averlo già vinto è perché
non penso che se arrivate di ti fa
vincere sarebbe intatto o forse sì
nel buio potremmo arrivare intatti
ok
yes e vedi che non ti faceva ricavi però
sono arrivato completamente intatto
ragazzi c'è il massimo e il massimo che
si può volere l'altro livello
se proprio vogliamo ok
boh meraviglioso tutto onesto next north
pole rush va bene va bene va bene ok
time to fly bataille to fly anche prima
in realtà decido io se permetti che mai
e vabbè vabbè fa niente sono vivo
voglio anche senza i folletti che
livello pazzesco
questo non so se avevo mai fatto raiuno
questo è veramente pazzesco parchi ha
bisogno di colle si sorvola ruolo anche
senza fantastico another die menschen
dal set
quante di mese a noi che non era fatto
da quello di prima che faccia i livelli
sono invenzioni ok laboratorio non sa
che col camice inguardabile se
permettete la tavola periodica di happy
wheels boh
tricks oscar 23 welcome idee giacomo i
brani grazie mille
gli orari ai preti non lo shalke e manda
migliore vuoi anche nel futuro medioevo
anche nel passato vedi pane tipo vecchio
doc 7 milioni 87 c'è quel numero di ok
l'avevo già fatto questo che ci fa
vedere pd si crei di c'è un pi greco che
vola senza un motivo
va bene che brutto il mondo tra 785
milioni di anni se posso permettere un
po una merda cioè non è proprio il
massimo invece di meglio sei uscito la
nostra della il continuum spazio
temporale bo vabbè cosa che succede
quando gioia per la voglio affatto
ragazzi non era niente di strano alla
fine finiva così era veramente anche
bypassabile se vogliamo avevo fatto
mille volte se infatti ragazzi hanno già
fatto troppe volte però sempre bello
ricordarsi i vecchi tempi lager tutto a
posto e ci sono alcuni livelli che non
ho fatto mai della classifica mondiale
che questa e sono alcuni che ho fatto
la scusa di là
è un po
ho vinto con le braccia
scusatemi
no veramente capirla sta roba scusate un
atomo come ho fatto a fare come ho fatto
a vincere ho vinto con le braccia che
non me lo spiego
anno con la testa
ok la testa andata nella vittoria
perfetto era quello che non capivo era
questo che non stavo capendo sono uscito
a vincere con la testa va bene after
damned riproviamoci non ho capito niente
però va bene
avrei voluto seguire la testa per vedere
che fine ha fatto è un po lo rifacciamo
ok tutto per tutto a posto è un normale
livello di happiness
boh
è quindi è riuscito a vincerlo solo
prima bocca non ho capito il senso di
suntech mansion andiamo avanti va out
mansion gioca con me voglio soltanto un
amico si certo
forse devo leggerlo in inglese sono spia
male risparmi audi one and friends e
[ __ ] shore a largo che va bene per
quale ma che cosa devo fare col salto a
bicchia liuc è veramente eh vabbè c'è
uno zombie tutto a posto va bene onesta
sta roba più che stai calma non è forza
alterarti eva perche uno zombie per
terra dottor crane a chi cacchio salve
vado sotto anno dopo saltar mannaggia al
cacchio difficilissimo a questo penso
che sia veramente vecchio di livello
perché non ha neanche i tic madonna
yes o verranno fa piacere c'è gente
morta bello suo livello un gallego sono
contento che abbiano fatto successo
questi livelli di nelle fogne nelle
fogne e signori livello number one wine
cellar e ami già praticamente amnesia
come chiamatelo volete e quello macello
offrire la cella del vino china mesi al
cielo non c'è in altri giochi
la curiosità uccide ma non me come ci
siamo finiti in questa veramente scomoda
situazione amico mio
come abbiamo fatto a finirci me lo
chiedo molto volte sono contento del
fatto 100 episodi certo quello che dico
spesso specialmente quando mi dimentico
che c'è quello che mi ammazza
specialmente quando muori 66 volte nello
stesso modo è quello il fatto va bene
bello vero dunque un livello allegro
l'importante che si parte che livelli
siano allegri ragazzi poi fa niente se
mi riferendo di una sega sono vivo sono
livorno non so come non fate sono corso
non a croce guarda uguale la posizione
della stessa non ho capito come sia
possibile ma fa niente
cleri e se credo di essere molto più
aerodinamico così non vorrei è una
cagata
ma secondo me così vado più veloce del
solito l'allegria briano ma infatti
allegro suo livello
giosuè welcome intesa come brother anche
davide grazie mille per lavorazioni
ragazzi thank you so much and well com
la curiosità uccide quindi non andiamo
più dove uccide andiamo dall'altra parte
sono molto areodinamico così parecchio
e ogni altro indietro indietro è
perfetto non facciamoci uccidere dalla
curiosità ragazzi andiamo avanti che
porta questo era il periodo in cui
andavano di horror come giochi si vede
anche per katy louise e così è pizarro è
impossibile sta cosa cioè è raro però
non è più un episodio di aprile all ok
pochi c'è un po di line in questa
allegria ma infatti che cacchio è cosa
mi rappresenta stringhe
vediamo se questa roba riesce cioè non
ho veramente capito il senso di tutto
ciò prova i tempi sono scuole da un
action e andiamo con non lo sa che
vogliamo vincere ma l'ho scelto io non
ho fatto che non mi sembra troppo
indicato questo livello sono finisco
quale nuovo apre ma che fico
no ragazzi you love me no no no no mi
spiace non ti incassare sui calciatori
treviso una specie di spirito hi e miur
husbands fatto sto livello sono tuo
marito di no crema string che strano
però madonna che che che presa male
prima destra certo quando a destra
doveva che vada
ok è tutto a posto
è una fickman oh mio dio ma che figata
ma chi che ha fatto se quando si è messo
a fare sta roba che va tutto livello
madonna che bordello assurdo ma non
approvo la mia scusate se non ha finito
di spiegare ma mi ha un attimo scioccato
questa specie di orsetto con le braccia
freedom
molto allegro non è mite che so much for
the nation
c'è un odore come stai sicura sempre sei
un grande grazie non è bacio sto molto
bene e soprattutto sto molto bene
sapendo che sono arrivato a 200 episodi
a chi visse senza morì d'infarto prima
cosa che era molto probabile giocando un
sacco di horror però tutto a posto
porta lo sfrido desco il portale il
portale della libertà
ok ok
ok continuiamo a corno un continuo
ancora perché se non a caso va bene va
bene vai vai vai vai se vogliamo non
andare più sono vivo mi ha tenuto in
gioco il braccio ok mi sa che devo
andare indietro per cosa non sta
suggerendo a doveva andare qua sotto
alla fine devo cadere ed il e io che
messaggi quindi stiamo sparando robe da
riportare tutto a posto
gli sparano dai portali ma tutto bene
ragazzi sta faccenda va tantissimo nel
2010 come me me se vogliamo proprio
dirla tutta non è indietro avanti bello
finora tutto a posto entro ancora
riportare il giorno mi troverò scola mia
follia da resisti portali sopportare che
conduce direttamente alla mia scuola
superiore non vorrei ritornarci se
bambini tutto ok
tutto ok a posto
[Musica]
ma non penso che tu possa hai vinto fan
non mi fai paura se milan ci faccine
lancia di roma più pericolosa minacciosa
non lo so il portale la libertà sempre
di mister fatality spero abbia fatto
successo nella vita se mister fatality
oggi si chiama stephen king
probabilmente prove senza braccia sembra
una salsiccia noi da te con le braccia
se non essere umano perché la times è
una salsiccia però del next one gadget
boyd stream blasco agent boy ma tommasi
che me lo ricordo questo correva
velocissimo sa troppo in alto però è il
si sta assestando le tecnologie poi
posso anche picchiare la gente è
bellissimo jet poi ragazzi ma che roba
jet boy è il mio personaggio preferito
di happiness ma se solo in questo
livello che si chiamava appunto apple è
il tentano di far amico i bazooka robe
strane ma che è successo
hanno sfondato tutto fratelli che doveva
andare così va bene già tuoi è
bellissimo
no
era arrivato al traguardo però io
l'appunto come io lo racconterei come
vittoria ragazzi secondo me ora conta
rigoni somewhere home page led che
dobbiamo vedere se riesco a fare un
somewhere home page che il classico
questo pilotandola la m io ma nel mentre
sono al telefono e questo è quello che
non è giusto c'è nel 66 al telefono e
piloti la m
e vabbè tutto a posto a posso ancora
andare avanti va bene eh vabbè e io che
volevo solo prendere la metro
va bene
questo ragazzi quando mi danno la
patente poi invece di usarla e va 3
subway rampage speriamo che queste
persone non siano diventati poi un
pericolo per la società facendosi
livelli però segway paul new nuove
intelligenze di intelligenza artificiale
va bene giampietro start a ok non devo
far sì che la bomba a tocchi la mia il
mio lato del campo va bene let's golf è
un pallavolo esplosivo simulator
mannaggia il gioco col computer tra
l'altro fighissimo con intelligenza
artificiale è un'idea addirittura sono
diventati intelligenze artificiali su e
cioè primi sono all intelligenza
artificiale e intelligenza molo
neuronica che è un'altra roba
diversamente intelligente e difatti io
ho perso
ok c'è scritto che è quasi impossibile
ma che c'è una piccola probabilità di
vittoria cervelo riassunta ho letto
quello che c'è scritto adesso che non
avevo letto
volevo leggere ovviamente questa
sconfitta l'ho fatta apposta per poter
leggere la seconda parte quindi non
credete
tali tranquilli l'ho fatto apposta oddio
è più forte di messi dirigenza
artificiale com'è possibile è più
intelligente di me ma cosa ma cosa come
ha fatto a salvarsi aiuto sono ancora
vivo in tutto ciò
ecco qua sto resisti allagato
addirittura c'è flight simulator
ma non è vero
madonna mi sono salvato la ragazza è
impossibile o dio no
mannaggia il cacchio è veramente
difficilissimo no ragazze non vincono me
ne vado non posso essere battuto dall
interesse e l'intelligenza artificiale
di happy wheels
adesso ho perso apposta certo ragazzi
sempre perso il posto io perdo sempre a
costa com te l'ho messa lì cacchio ci
arriva sempre però perché velocissima
come fate come si sa ma come ma come si
è salvato ok va bene va bene andiamo
avanti of cycle course corsa rosa quelli
molto easy
porca vacca sono morto
madonna è difficilissimo sono morta
l'inizio di uno stage il corso non mi è
mai successo
se moglie all'inizio dire che è
veramente difficile ok arpioni
attenzione grazie ve l'ho detto perchè
non me n'ero accorto speciale gli
arpioni abnormi mio dio tutto a posto
ok a posto c'è un braccio che vola ma
chi se ne frega
va bene va bene che a livello bellissimo
fai dei videogiochi sui treni cos'è
treni simulator ragazzi
esistono sono ma esiste prima che allora
ha fatto dopo schiacciare io non c'è o
ragazzi non ci sta arrivando vi giuro
facciamo che gli viola due ore qua e
arriva c o amen
quindi torna indietro
ok no è il fatto che si entra i ragazzi
mi destabilizza il cervello perché è
previsto non è mai stato
madonna l'inter rischia ragazzi sto
rischiando continuamente continuamente
[Musica]
devo calmarmi devo veramente calmarmi
nel frattempo vi ricordo siamo quasi
siamo a metà ragazzi siamo esattamente
no esattamente non può prima a metà
delle tre ore di e quindi con ragazzi
che le ultime due ore
farò fogari contesta ragazzi dalle 18
yamaha mi hanno ucciso file fa niente
taken 36 che nel senso di tekken o di
taken non ho letto niente ma vanno avere
rivelando un blade è sporco il demonio
morto suscita fare un livello in cui
sono morto in stanza ma perché mi i lupi
il figlio non che me ne freghi qualcosa
ma la domanda non ho capito se c'entra
niente con te che devo fare le file di
savona fight provvediamo le leggo 2 a
che livello di me
no scherzo sono io che sono scarso
aizone corsa e seven
eccoli prima a pro e del livello 2
ok se hanno fatto un secondo sono molto
titubante ma facciamolo
ecco appunto
ok tutto a posto ragazzi ma chi è che mi
ama i lanciate le faccine ma porco il
demonio incastrato nel duomo
ma perché ok yes
oddio ti ringrazio e veramente difficile
e allora a posto fest è così tranquillo
qui ecco corri un po vabbè ma tutto bene
no perché mi sembra un po meno male mi
ha salvato il culo bilancio così dal
cielo ma basta lanciare le faccine non
ha un senso tutto ciò lento mittente un
carato in mano meno male fa star
che culo ci sono passato per niente
clifton firme dispiace andare più in
auto in corsa
bravo mister fatality che fa solo i
livelli coppe del mondo gli altri non
dico di schifosi non li sa fare
nell ultima mezz oretta facciamo un non
adesso nell'ultima mentalità facciamo un
misto impossible ryan o anzi nell'ultimo
retta che dite che sono comunque i
livelli più di te lo ragazzi di commenti
nell'ultima oretta adesso manca ancora
mezz'oretta qua
nell'ultima oretta scoccate le due ore
fino alle 3 farei solo l'impossible
ditemi se vi sembra una buona idea
perché vorrei provare a fare che imposti
col possibili in un ora vediamo se
riesco
se vi piace sono conti comunque siete
dunque sono i die l'ultima mezz'oretta
fanno solo quello poi passiamo a for
guys apple shooter vincessero becco su
un fenomeno
vabbè avevi troppa fiducia in mezzo
emilia è un chilometro allora vediamo è
già meglio però poi sempre la merda no
qualcosa amici che ho sbagliato mira
però tutto a posto ci sta tantissimo va
bene ragazzi lo faccio
eccolo ci ho messo due ora prende sono
da meno sarebbe stato bello vincerla
subito però vediamo se riesco a sparare
anche più in basso ai ragazzi tipo ii no
non era proprio quella la mira di
scappare quello che volevo fare e non
era neanche questo non era questo non
era questo eccolo perfetto questo lo fa
maschietti non guardino se poi però
un'ora di bossi molto attenti perché la
tastiera potrebbe il signore fatti ma la
tastiera stasera 6 tranquilla tanto allo
lei lo sa lei lo sa non vi preoccupate
prima questi prima o poi si romperà
ragazze starving hobo questo livello
pixelato ragazzi anche questo l'ho fatto
tre volte non me ne frega niente lo
rifaccio è bellissimo è bellissimo è uno
dei più bei livelli di epiche secondo me
perché è lo stile che fa e lo stile fa e
questo livello ha stile devo credergli
sopra a sinistra
mi sa che devo prima dalla sinistra le
temps ok è un livello completamente
nonsense ragazzi non mi piaceva il pixel
da pixar
ragazzi vi ricordate megapixel madonna
mektic sarà bellissimo ma pixar madonna
che ricorda ogni volta che gioca sta
roba mi ricordo mai pixel non so per
quale motivo
sì perché fatto a pisa però sono cascato
da due chilometri fa niente prendo la
bistecca e le rifarei gozzo in gori e
credo di sì se l'hanno aggiornano
saranno aggiornati
tutto a posto comunque un livello
normale va bene andiamo avanti the
mystic che io ne ho fatti comunque
infatti è la prima donna infatti un
sacco da quando abbiamo iniziato ragazzi
dei mesi che il led maledettissimo got
to not enter e quindi mi fai andare
avanti allora ok dove tre gole live view
o dio dio devo trovare una chiave va
bene e la trovo addio tutto a posto
ragazzi tranquilli
mai mai mai mai mai ho rischiato ma me
ne frega niente vivo la mia vita un
quarto di happy questa al secondo
al minuto
ne ho fatti un sacco il fatto è che
questi sono anche più lunghi del normale
ragazzi ve l'ho detto
questi livelli di eclisse sono più
lunghi perché sono migliori quindi
importante che capiate la differenza da
un livello nel cacchio è il livello
fatto bene anche perché si vedono i
livelli fatti bene sorpresi stati tanti
sono di mertens
gol o no let's go tutto bene
fortuna che non so se mi serve per
entrare la caverna o se questa la
caverna c'è un occhio no sono stato in
una vagina
ma no che posso e cioè in fa freddo
fasce fried l'area dello yeti julie
white come in the già come i browser
grazie mille e lucia grazie alla nazione
grazie mille ragazzi l'area dello yeti
mm che cazzo ne freghiamo lo yeti a casa
quindi era di sopra perché non l'ho
visto sarah di sopra non l'ho neanche
visto quindi figuriamoci ho la schiena
un pelo mi sono alzato stamattina con un
po di mal di schiena non capisco da che
cosa sia dovuto
ok adesso a posto pericolo essere avere
amici chiropratici ti dà una mano
qualcuno mi spiega il senso visto
livello no perché più vado avanti più
non trovo un senso alla mia stessa vita
quindi figuriamoci a livello stesso sono
andato anche sono andata a casa dello
yeti sotto nel sottomarino
boh ora l'album cosa ha detto va bene ma
mi sono pagato non fa niente non fa
niente ragazzi tutto a posto tutto a
posto
l'ascensore veramente ora di là perché
fanno gli acesi se vale ancora qui sotto
c'è il centro della terra ma forse fine
siete resi conto chi sei tu esci da qua
va bene mi scusi non posso uscire è
chiuso non avresti dovuto farlo ma e non
si può uscire ho provato mi scusi non
volevo e non si può uscire qua ho
provato sino si esce
mi scusi ma perché mi lancia le rocce
non si può uscire a sinistra ma per
favore ma cosa ti ho fatto io
vabbè io vado avanti perché noi non vi
si cucite
volevo io volevo uscire senza danni
fastidio ma non si poteva cedere la
caverna mistica di mister fatality
chissà chi è il suo spacciatore ragazzi
non lo sapremo mai
forse è meglio the office the office e
una serie tv partiamo da questo
presupposto ma non c'entra niente è un
livello di acquisti dove c'è un ufficio
gigante e io sono un nano senza testa a
posto tutto a posto
la sexy la safezone servivano farti
colpire grazie mille del avermelo detto
ragazze madonna sto telefono è veramente
impossibile
ma va o che ce l'ho fatta ho trovato che
ho fatto quando dei posti non dovrebbe
essere un livello difficile questo
livello
environment di bellezza ti guardi in
giro e vedi che fatto bene invece io
muoio io ci muoio in questo livello che
non è un livello da morte però va bene
ho superato i post it perfetto perfetto
a spina la corrente la tolgo don't film
beh anche dabato il tutto questo momento
ho detto lui vado dai poveri rifaccio
ragazzi che è veramente impossibile
mi stupisce il fatto che non sia
riuscendo a farlo ma vabbè ok allora con
la gamba
se tu usi la propulsione fi molto più
danno è come se fosse la mia ultima
league of legends così guarda e questa
cosa serve per stimolare un po più il
tuo corpo quando hai rabbia sulla
tastiera non sempre mi spiace non volevo
ma è così ecco questo calcio mi ha fatto
spostare la schermata molto divertente
comunque questo livello mi piace fatto
bene
ma se io vado risolvono modo di sapere
che c'è il telefono che una salsiccia ok
deve evitare di andare contro il topo in
tutto questo ok perfetto ma non ci passo
ok non ho capito se era una mossa di
danza vecchione una scarpa
c'è una scarpa gigante va bene non sto
capendo niente di colori è stato cioè il
telefono una salsiccia non è infatti
maroni non facciamoci domanda ragazzi
andiamo pure avanti
caos city la città del caos come livello
non mi aspetto niente di strano è se non
un disastro dietro l'altro aiuto
sono finito nel bidone dell'immondizia
come gli ultimi 200 episodi di happy c'è
uno struzzo è perché non dovrebbe
esserci
scusatemi non superare a farlo quando
non sa che queste cose mi ispira la
corsa veloce e colmano jacques quei
razzi ai tutto di che guadagnato questa
frase non è italiana che voi lo sappiate
no
lo vedo io mannaggia il cacchio
suck it losers non capisco bene se
effettivamente possono sfondare st
finestra secondo me no perché la vanitas
con data di debutto però sarebbe stato
divertente
cacchio è fatta di amianto famiglia
indietro e lo voglio fare con uno shock
e ragazzi se lo so che non è fa non è
facile col nonno ma gli sfila velocità e
[ __ ]
torniamo personaggio meno male
l'importante è rimanere nelle proprie
idee ragazzi non farsi mai so giocare
dalle cose ma rimanere nella propria
idea sempre forti ragazzi importante
questo allora ragazzi little nightmare
little nightmares lo vedo che me lo
state chiedendo tutti e quindi ragazzi
adesso vi spiego questa cosa la little
nightmares era un gioco che mi sono
pagato solo io ai tempi di telai di
mister lei come sono quindi com'è
possibile che adesso me lo chiedono
tutti me lo so se uscisse outlast 3 cosa
che uscirà alla fine lo capisco ma scusa
il the light berlo giocato ed ho
guardato solo che il mio lidl italia
come mai la gente infognata lignite
nightmares come avete fatto
come avete fatto ragazzi a con o anche
solo a conoscerlo visto che quando lo
portai sul canale l'avevo portato
praticamente
solo io cioè non sono io ma l'avevo
portato ma non era piaciuto così tanto
perché adesso tutti mi chiedono l'inter
nei per la mia risposta tutto questo è
che quelli lì dell'iceberg hanno fatto
una pubblicità pazzesca a tal punto da
destare interesse anche a chi non ha
giocato il primo perché come non si
spiega come mai tutti quanti mi chiedono
l'iter il the light mers non è non è
così conosciuto e poi a me lo chiudo in
me lo chiedono tutti di gioco andava
giocato il primo me lo ero cagato solo
io cioè quasi sullo strano sta cosa
dunque certo farò lite let me su due ha
voglia e come se lo farò solo che mi
stupisce che tanti siano così
interessati ma pm hanno chiesto tutti
possiamo guardare i due video
scommettere ok
quante voglia di andare la bici serve
per andare avanti avanti non indietro
avanti guarda qua c'è scritto anche qua
dove era che ci ha scritto impostazioni
non è un'impostazione eccolo qua no
india avanti vedi che è rotto tasto
avanti quindi per forza non funziona
grazie perché mi si deve smistare la
seta per quale motivo mi rema contro sto
gioco tutto bene
è la madonna che godzilla contro come si
chiamava quello massimo da cell plus ma
c'era di tutti sta il suo livello
veramente kirby clown age maghette fu
mezzi l'hotel va bene questo mi sembra
tutto fuorché un hotel ragazzi ma vabbe
fa niente va bene sono all'interno di
non so che cosa ma fa niente nè un hotel
questo ragazzo è una camera di tortura
ma fa nulla dove vuoi andare push push
poi andare ha visto la al ristorante si
al ristorante si ok ciao
salve tutto bene allora il menù di oggi
zuppa carne di maiale e banana nel
ghiaccio voglio una banana del ghiaccio
per favore mela una banana di ghiaccio
del gradi dai grazie pero passare sui
tavoli per fare questa cosa ok
insomma non ci passa perché sono troppo
non salta fino lì ve ne siete accorti
che lui non salta fino agli ultrà mix
amx commenta giacomo ce l'ho fatta una
banana con ghiaccio salva i paragoni a
ciò che poiché merda la bara gogna c'e
cioè che si mangiano a barack obama
perché dove si mangia ma lo mangi pure
gli action che cacchio è la banana con
il ghiaccio bombe
[Musica]
non ho capito niente ma andiamo avanti
ragazzi la nota è la mano allo ragazzi
allora gira la piramide degli dei due è
il livello più difficile che io abbia
mai fatto su happy bis allora non sono
mai riuscito a finirlo perché c'è
veramente ci sono tre boss fight
all'interno mai finito proviamo a vedere
se per qualche strano motivo stavolta
riesco se non riesco non fa niente
allora abbiamo ancora 14 minuti dai o 14
minuti per trovare ve lo ricordate
questo bel avevo fatto allora c'è un
episodio di happy meals che si chiama il
livello più difficile del mondo la roba
del genere comunque io in quel video di
apriso ho fatto solo questo livello
c'è un video dove io faccio solo un
livello e non l'ho finito non lo figli
non lo non l'ho mai finito non l'ho mai
finito o 14 minuti per provarci ragazzi
e vi assicuro che non ce la farò a fare
quanto per un episodio intero che dice
ho provato per tanti minuti non 14 e non
sono comunque riuscito quindi io vi
assicuro che secondo me in 14 minuti io
non riesco a fare che non riusciva a
fare il suo livello proprio diamoci
horus ok dovrei averlo fatto
horus l'ho fatto ce ne sono tre ragazzi
ve lo ricordate quali era veramente
impossibile comunque primo l'ho fatto ho
ancora tredici minuti per riuscirci sono
meno già farò mai però va bene
l'informazione c'è horus che l'abbiamo
fatto poi c'è isis il dio
la dea del della salute e del wisdom
vigoroso voglio dire wisdom vorrei
chissenefrega sagge no non mi ricordo
vabbè osiris il dio dell'after la vita
dopo la morte
e poi c'è l'occhio di sauron a piramide
la verità ma vero più avanti dai no
ragazzi anche se non facessi impulsivo
dopo comunque in un'ora e 13 più chi non
ce la farei comunque bra sicuro per
farvi capire quanto impossibile comunque
andiamo avanti questo è questo gli
impose questo è l'unico cento per cento
questa è l'unico cento per cento
possible di tutto è più vista ragazzina
eccoci qua siamo già morti a dire ciao
ovviamente evitare i costi
[Musica]
è la prima morte
l'abbiamo fatta andiamo per la prossima
ragazzi volte numero uno e le contiamo e
morte numero uno
altri 12 minuti ragazzi prima morte ma
aspettate tranquilli tranquilli
tranquilli don't worry 131 adesso ho
compreso un po di più lo faccio un po
più fest
preparato i ragazzi al cento per cento
impossible che è questo
ecco morto rue che fa niente morte il
numero due
restate
pato vi rimane in dieci minuti
già quattro mesi se ne sono andati va
bene ho fatto fuori un box di quattro no
3 perché no che non ho capito che sono
tre o quattro perché la piramide non ci
sono neanche mai arrivato questo serve
quando continua a slittare la pagina
teoria dovrei aver fissato il problema
credo 12
forse se lo lascio ce la faccio
ecco cipro 3 ci sono quattro le botte di
lodare ok 4
la chiave è grazie mille
eccoci raga cento per cento in prossimo
tentativo numero due
perché horus ancora ancora eccoci qua ma
anche a dieci minuti ancora bene isis
la vita ri colpita tensione due volte la
buono non ci vado adesso lo sapevo
estate lo diceva questo
[Applauso]
tremorti ragazzi rifacciamolo
e chissà perché poi voi avete visto
l'episodio montato quindi quei tagli ma
chissà qua io non visto io che sono
stato due ore a provarci e poi era
arrivato al massimo
che poi comunque lo sto facendo un
brutto risultato è perché ero arrivato a
questo massimo credo
poi vabbè vediamo le scolpito di hope è
stato proprio il piede fortissimo è
stato molto doloroso secondo me è che
devono amici fa male fidatevi come una
botta di quelle che ti ricordi da acide
horus gran botta è rischiato a posto la
chiave è meravigliosa a rifarlo
leasys sarebbe in italia in italiano che
non mi intendo niente osiride boh
mamma forse non è potuto dargli subito
la seconda botta ma nel senso letterale
o bianchi
[Applauso]
ora forse ancora vivo no ovviamente solo
morto però volevo vedere se riesco a
volevo né se riuscirò a colpirla con un
arto quarta morte
iside isid era la mia prof
alle medie tutto a posto
ma quattro ragazzi perfetto morte count
4 mancano 7 minuti ragazzi e siamo già a
metà vedere le divinità egizie presi
altri cdc cliccate fino alla morte e una
e ragazzi stiamo parlando di happy
questi di sicuro la miglior film miglior
modo di studiare mi sono salvato ma
veramente non so come perché lo più
sotto
diceva il miglior modo di studiare che
esista anche la storia possiamo fidare
suo ep days a biciclettate hanno preso
anche l'arciduca ferdinando
poi scoppia tower a bicicletta sicuro è
tutto così ne è più di voi la storia del
suap i quiz che sono asiatiche forte
donation ti seguo da il marzo 2013
quinto episodio che fiennes mamma mia
e comunque ragazzi per arrivare gia fin
qua vi assicuro che non è facile
no ho sbagliato
mannaggia siamo a 5
questo è uno dei livelli più belle più
ben fatti tutto è triste se non fosse
che è non è fini pile e quello l'unico
peccato visto livello che avrà finito
sono chi l'ha fatto perché è di un non
si può fare cioè che non si può fare
cime perché poi ci metti veramente già è
difficile se ci fossero i check point
sarebbe già difficile c'è già uno dei
nostri checkpoint
c'è veramente beneficio di dark souls
rassicuro global games the kid thank
insomma c'è fratello grazie mille per il
bel commento della donazione brother
ma a 5 minuti e in tutto questo in
cinque minuti dall'uscita fare sta roba
la vedo grigia ma ci proviamo
ok
da in programma allora botta subito e
adesso botta di nuovo ok adesso piano
botta di nuovo che hai piano
ora devo aspettare secondo me esatto
[Musica]
ora devo andare indietro tanto aspetto
tanto ragazzi perché anzi mi conviene
aspettare un po qua per mischiare
proprio le carte ok un po siamo a sei o
non avevo neanche sfiorato bump sono
stato fermo perché sai come sempre lo
stesso pattern i laser però ho visto che
vado sempre imperterrito di questa un po
fermo così si mischiano lasagne
impossibile quattro minuti ragazzi vedo
ancora due tentativi alla all'orizzonte
the last 2
credo è immagino bene tipo a memoria ok
oh yeah l'ok ad espropri mai aspetta che
in realtà era un medley facciamo le
diciamo le cose fatte bene che ci manca
s1 per la prima battaglia un sangue
indietro dio mio
sono vivo e non so come non fate domande
non ne ho idea sono vivo però tutto a
posto tutto molto strano ovunque ma
papam è ma ci sono troppi
ci sono troppi arti miei in giro il che
mimì mi dà troppo fastidio
cioè non mi permette di essere preciso
lei ma sbaglio si sta recuperando pure
la vita quello fare prima ma si recupera
la vita ma pure ma sì ma tanto era
facile si recupera anche la vita non è
non gli andava giù
se si reco pure quindi l'ho pure a fare
veloce secondo me i ragazzi non si può
finire se recupera vita non lo posso
venire perché non posso andare veloce
perché se vado veloce muoio per chi la
sa sono fatti apposta per non andare
veloce eli cotec fate donation siamo a
58 quindi l'ultimo tentativo vediamo
credo che sia fatto apposta per non
essere finito però magari mi sbaglio rio
chissà se qualcuno l'ha mai finito suo
livello vestiamo a biciclettate horus
perché mi sembra la cosa più giusta
ok a piazza del fisico di horus è the
rock praticamente ok morto yes
riproviamoci che vedevo di e l'ultimo
questo è ragazzi o forse non c'è ancora
se muoio subito c'è ancora tempo di un
altro
vediamo
minchia sono scivolato troppo da questo
make us by oraria che perdo tempo il
prima che sei attacco con accanto
[Applauso]
la battuta non battuta la chiave bene
sono morto però la battuta va bene sono
contento di questo perché il mio corpo
ci è finito sopra dopo che sono morto
però vabbè veggente goal.com in de
giacomo ragazzi grazie mille vi seguo da
quando ero piccolo comunque è fatta
veramente bene questa mappa peccato solo
per il fatto che sia fatta male non
scherzo è fatto veramente bene e che è
impossibile se con me nessuno ha mai
finito perché come fai
però figo va bene questo era al cento
per cento il prossimo
vi è chris impossibile sono le due sono
passate due ore volevo dire sono le
cinque e un quarto
sono passate le donne e vado a bere una
roba al volo quindi mette un attimo in
pausa e facciamo nell'ultima ora un bel
rush di un'oretta di impossible solo in
posti come ragazzi quindi aspettatevi il
peggio arrivo tra 120 secondi
ora è più
beh ai bucks mancano signori un circa 54
minuti ho visto che cè sta cosa qua e
vorrei vedere se riusciamo a fare
appunto un sacco di imposti con la cosa
[ __ ] e che credo non avrà mai fatto
un'ora di imporsi col grazie a dio
grazie a dio li proviamo a giocare
allora prima di farlo allora ho
sbagliato perché sono già uscito eccoci
qua abbiamo fatto fino a pie lamis of
the gods che ovviamente è stata la
nostra della e ne abbiamo fatto lo
possiamo contare visto che è impossibile
lo contiamo anche se non abbiamo fatto
stiamo a metà vai facciamo un mezzo 1 2
3 4 5 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 15
17 18 19 20 21 22 23 56 il 78 il 30 come
30 34 e 35 36 livelli ho fatto 36
livelli in due ore che non è male non è
male sono 18 livelli ha ora è più o meno
è quello che faccio quando faccio un
singolo episodi happy with 36 anni e
mezzo se voglio montare anche l'ultimo
allora vediamo che cosa esce fuori gli
ultimi livelli che hanno fatto per
curiosità che di che cosa si parla con
quella gente continua a giocare ad apple
stessa cosa non la capisco ma vabbè poi
parlo io allora
società in game prima di prima di
cercare imposte volevo fare una roba
lo sapevo anno fa sono solo questi ok
sono solo cinque livelli di faul guys
tra cui questo che il più giocato
vediamo come fatto per curiosità è solo
pura curiosità ok ok ma non c'entra
niente io penso avessero fatto gli omini
invece non c'entra nulla con for guys
specialmente è una specie di corsa ad
ostacoli
va bene ovviamente perché la gente che
gioca for guys non gioca più epis ma
gioca for guys va bene ho perso non era
mai la per curiosità volo solo vedere
che cacchio usciva fuori niente di
strano veniva con gli ha disegnati
proprio ma hanno fatto solo corse a
ostacoli in tutto ciò va bene sono anche
bravo dio fu psi daisy e questo fa gas
un far west e ai poveri si esatto ultra
mx uguale for guys for free diamo eccolo
qua il colore di sfondo c centra
parecchio solo quello vero mi sa che
l'essere livello farà cagare
matt nix knock out bello è proprio
follia melo uguale volgari swart rom o
finalmente vede una faccia che somiglia
a uno di folger c'è solo quello
praticamente va bene cascate in due
ok niente fino all'ultimo gli ho giocati
tutti è le giocate a questo quale altra
corsa a ostacoli e quello di prima
riproviamoci altro punto che gioco di
marca che strano che mi viene in mente
di fare sti livelli quasi web che se
lasciamo perdere il prossimo
vado a scrivere ma già allora plays
count va bene siete pronti a questi
cinquanta minuti di sofferenze interne
bordatura merenda
com
ho visto il trailer di outlet tre
ragazzi lo porteremo a volevo vedere
voglio vedere al volo scusatemi quanti
vi abbiamo fatto allora little
nightmares provinciale di un attimo
little nightmares aveva fatto ai tempi
1,3 milioni di visualizzazioni che non è
male
la usa talk in live equa che non è male
solo che non è tanto perché se tu fai
outlast fa vj questo aveva fatto
tantissimo quindi qual è il discorso
me l'hanno me l'avete pushato come se
fosse outlast il che mi ha sorpreso
perché i tempi non era così seguito
quindi meno male con pietro si esatto
bellissimo porterò l'intel end su due ha
voglia
meno male che vi è piaciuto così tanto e
come se un gioco che siano pagati in due
poi esce il 2 e dico tutti nuovo fallo
fallo uno si sorprendano quel 50 minuti
l'ex coop
questo non è un impossible questa non è
la modella però finito e vabbè è il
primo abbiamo fatto impossible poco e
anche il secondo non è vero sarebbe
stato bellissimo però è anche secondo
non è vero
e anche il secondo ce lo siamo volto
perfetto se ma due impossible arora anna
non volevo vedere nessuno replay
[Musica]
eccoci a ma aspetta aspetta questo non è
un imposta questa è una paura né basta
ai 20 in prossimo il bel click day tale
ma non è un imposto da marchionne è
cascato luke da davanti non paga
porca vacca c'ero e non lo shock
fidatevi guardare mi sono fidato poco io
di me stesso dovevo andare molto più
avanti non sono più vivo peccato la
battigia facciano tuo arrivo
[Musica]
peccato era era fatta raga era fatta
devo solo volare in alto per evitare la
che mi becchino garelli azioni tutto qua
vorrei tanto felici a quota se riesci
tipo flight simulator delle dita altri
video ecco veramente difficile ma con la
faccia facciamo ragazzi devono metterci
ai premi infatti the next one impossible
jump
oddio bellissimo ecco a posto
forse riesco e ragazzi aspettare un
attimo nell'ancora testa l'ultima parola
adesso è detta invece let's go maledetto
il mio culo
eccoci o un po le tibie spappolate ma fa
niente quello che fa fratello the next a
questo è uno spy phone travestito da
impossible che dovrei riuscire comunque
a far madonna che lancio di testa devo
superare il l'arancione almeno ecco che
già è già più fatti è molto difficile
comunque pre fattibile
ma già il cacchio numero mi piacere
questa era facile questa era facile era
facile da vincere sono stato stupido io
mannaggia mi ha preso la bici se mi
attaccava la mia bici secondo me ce la
facevo no qua ma la vita
questa è veramente difficile ai ragazzi
ma se mi rimango così madonna saperlo
prima bastava scendere dritti a sto
punto c'è di dritto porca vacca però un
po meno
leggete goku upgrade a piergiorgio te
che so much ragazzi grazie mille vi
seguo da quando mi picchiava te
nella prima stagione aspettati madonna
ma possibile mai che non è poi così
impossibile con lo è fatto
eccoci la guarda
non fate domande avevano capito neanche
io questo sia successo ma vabbè il
prossimo il 70 per cento
se mi veniva se mi veniva mataj hayward
ma si fa niente
the next 96,7 ma vabbè vabbè vabbè vabbè
c'è un po di va bene in questa rai c'è
un po di live di questo vabbè ho vinto
ero vivo
ero vivo ragazzi vi giuro ma come non
ragazzi di gioco che vi giuro che ero
bimbo ve lo giuro ha forse c'è una bomba
poi da prendere a ok però era arrivato
vivo prima che strano a ben ex per
adesso tutto a posto era niente di che è
tutto ok tutto onesto tutto prive di un
po di vabbè dopo
io volevo fare così è mica mi caga chi
esattamente quello che avete visto
volevo fare questo perfetto va bene
ma sai che non ce li vede stesse per
folgaria
li sento e non so fino a che ora fanno
live e ragazzi potrei sentirli andando
un po cara stefy non so fino a che la i
medici ma alle 18 il caldo
ecco perché mi risponde non lo so perché
magari aveva già iniziato distacca prima
vado vado un po di vado dopo poco il
demonio morto ieri
tutto bene ragazzi non so come ho fatto
dopo lo vedo il replay per l'attenzione
che non è finita lo concretizzare
[Musica]
ecco fammi davanti ho fatto ma cosa mi
sono parato con la sedia
c'è una roba da un fenomeno deve cucina
abbiamo cinque anni è complicato
impossible fondo e cristiano amico mio
abbracciami guascone grazie mi ha dato
nation caro oddio ho portato giusto
tizio non volevo scusami tre club di sky
news in touche l'human ok scudo umano e
vabbè ma significa solo a me che te devo
dì scudo umano
ma non serve e vi trafigge mi trafigge
tutti quanti e non è fatto di abyan di
titanio sto tizio
non so non so come non so come ho fatto
non so non ho neanche ma se la riguardo
al ralenti se la riguardo al rallenty io
ti giuro che non saprei mai rifarla non
so con quale culo finale è tutto al suo
orco il demonio maledetto
yes questa prima risposto vediamo la
peggio fino alle 20 circa quindi scrivi
appena ci sei perfetto al 18 e 10 più o
meno deve finire alle 18 10 entro
precise entro
max faremo for guys o chiede cristiano
tè freddo nation my brother
grazie faremo una crossover di live
ragazzi spettacolo vediamo chiamate
tutti è
o faremo una live incrociata non è mai
allora non è mai successo nella storia
del mio canale di fare una live
incrociata mai
quindi mentre non sono in live io sono
in live chiamate tutti perché questo è
un momento storico punto ho finito alle
8 tutti dalle 8 alle 18
quindi tra mezz'ora tutti connessi 18 e
10 perché inizial 18 10 tutti mi
raccomando sarà finale finale chiamateli
minuto del gol
chi stato il prossimo lor noto io spero
di yes
e invece no però aspetta che ciò questa
tattica di aiab di static pazzesca che
hai praticamente ai spinge myself fronte
muro in the left eye spingere to the
right with the pongo is very difficult
but it week end to this ai dai ai mori
muoio lo stesso
quindi ragazzi come se lo faccio ma non
si può farla la gamba ha preso la gamba
ha preso la moneta e cristiano grazie
mille per il supporto madonna che salto
io veramente non so come fare sta roba
ma si può cambiare personaggio no e
quindi come io faccio
non so come ho fatto a [ __ ] gli
arpioni ma ok il prossimo album
vediamo non è vero mai nella vita
8 goal no goal no goal
yes
3,37 del cop ragazzi sta andando molto
bene comunque mi sono fiero di me stesso
non lo shuttle non so mai cosa mettere
nel possibile ma non si può fare a meno
che non lascia la sedia e ma io aspetto
sempre spetta
e mobile
ok bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye e
fate fatta è fatta pgt basta
[Applauso]
nonno tira fuori quei tre addominali che
hai fatto da ragazzo bravo bravo che non
c'è chi sono io la vecchia rotta era
solo che ha la barba quindi non so se
sia vero
25 secondi da me non importa importante
finirlo questo fai infattibile
semplicemente uno vota 5 stelle qua per
sbloccare sta roba
ok il prezzo è finire lo stesso
mannaggia che devo fare piano ragazzi
con il problema
no si ok a posto io dirti hacker ma cosa
dirti hacker ma tu sorella un dirti
hacker
a parte il fatto che si erano tutti
tolti gli arpioni quindi potevo andare
tranquillamente senza e se prendo le
monete vincolo se hanno le monete non le
posso presenti c'è un così c'è un muro
invisibile come faccio a vincere non si
può vincere c'è un muro in visione
prende una moneta non ci arrivo non si
può vincere larga non si può perché se
io faccio così e poi prendo il coso non
me lo prendo di là del dl di hacker
sporco hacker ma andate a cagare non lo
posso finire suo livello 92 per cento in
posti wright fi wi fi find the secret
files by the sea life and find the
secret
e che cazzo c'è qualcosa di nascosto
ah eccolo qui ma se lo voglio finire
normale si può finire
[Musica]
secondo me sì allora impossibile tanto
ragazzi io ho giocato tutti questi anni
af senza avere un account di è primis
perché non ho un account di happy with
cioè vedi che ci sono gli account
non ho mai avuto un account di filippo
grazie per la donazione che grazie mille
anche cristiano game grazie mi lagaro
thank you so much per il supporto di
oggi ragazzi grazie mille vediamo
gli ex sono un fenomeno di bossico raga
che doveva forse fare tutte le pagine
volendo stato fatto questo passo
indietro no se verrà rimesso anche più
avanti rock swing centro luca non era un
rock swing ma che culo trascinati prima
che uccida qualcosa letale e letale
letale non ce la faccio sono ti trascini
muore muore fila di mori morivo
tantissimo mi chiami giocava final
destination ho visto ragazzi so cos'è
letale vi faccio vedere
vi prego guardate mori ma tantissimo
cioè non so come ho fatto a vincere vi
assicuro che è difficilissimo
vi assicuro che vincere è difficilissimo
non so come ho fatto al primo tentativo
raga non so come è fatta perché
impossibile
ve lo giuro cioè l'unico modo per
vincere forse colpirlo prima perché non
so come ho fatto a usato col pci prima e
poi vai avanti ma è difficile uguale ok
non la lasciamo un muro invisibile
andiamo avanti a tutto a posto
l'inter è ormai ormai come gioca a
tombola
no no
gli yes no niente ragazzi vicissimo
prossimo piano ma molto più piano tipo a
o b detto piano ecco questo è buono ed
ipad ora non è così difficile
no dio mio
eccolo due ore ragazzi questa veramente
difficile questo era questo era
veramente strano come impossible ma lo
stesso senso molto difficile vescovo
però devi stare calma si è fatto di non
ho già casey non credo sia più ad altri
dal canto
a meno che non faccio così ah no prova
però a cambiare spettanze vuole farla
vedere con lui che non c'entra niente
un carro armato ciò vivo oramai che sono
vivo ma c'è il carrello rotto e un carro
armato questo puoi vincere qualsiasi
cosa con questo volendo tanto non si
possono mai colpire tranne resto sia
effettivamente se mi metto se mi metto
laterale non mi colpiscono ormai
nell'alto perfetto che fossimo il jump
del visivo è a devo saltare quindi non è
non devo prendere fuoco
ok da minino ciak ies è la madonna
ok era più facile del previsto
impossible wave i due
dio mio
e non ci arrivo
quello che non mi allungo all'inizio e
non si possa arrivare con uno già che
pirla ma anche se mi lascio andare prima
in un partito ci arriva sulla sella
oppure ci dev'essere un modo legale
[Applauso]
ma secondo me non visse castro aveva
niente
[Musica]
ecco come ho fatto ma non ho capito però
vabbè non fa niente non è tale per cento
ragazzi in chiama stai calmo tutto bene
ragazzi però ormai dai allora io
rimorchio così ai ragazzi voleva qualche
bravo che sono che bravo a fare sti
livelli se non rimorchi così suit
interattivo questi fori j
sono lorenzo mi chiama denso di cinque
anni gioco e psv col imposti per questo
il mio la mia capacità di riuscire a
rimorchiare questa solo pensa
non fate domande a posto sono le manca
mezz'ora in tutto questo l'ho già fatti
un sacco era in mezz'ora hanno fatti
tantissimi sono veramente fiero di me
stesso
tranne quelli che non si possono fare
che va beh no difficile prendere
l'angolatura giusta addio no eh vabbè a
persona era male o bruttissimo ecco non
ho capito cosa ho fatto me va bene
impossible art questi ragazzi sono i più
classici ministro solo il fatto di
cercare solo questi
cosa come perché non fatevi di vedere
[Musica]
ma cosa ma cosa presepe per il resto
delle persone che ha giocato suo livello
tranne me comunque come vedete raffinata
si aprono vedete la mia tastiera a tasti
biglietti vi sono più scavati degli
altri per molte guardate al microscopio
questa tenta neanche microscopico malata
occhio nudo di somme mo riguarda gli
guardali come stickies nichi si prende
tutti i livelli
madonna proprio lui il prossimo il 68
per cento non l'ho mai letto però ho
fatto in compenso passivo jumpc
sull'impossibile raga non c'era il pocho
è veramente estate e la tipologia di
riveli più difficile che c'è ed alla
quale mi sono squillato di più nella
storia ci penso di essere il ninja di
fort tait negli in pochi lo stoke è a
posto
vabbè
così 69 le maho giusto
[Musica]
[Applauso]
non sto capendo cosa dovrei fare in
questo perché non ci sono troppe cose da
fare se non andare avanti però non ho
una tecnica ea ok ma ho capito ma non
era non ha una fine ma non è una non
hanno messo un finale ma allora ma scusa
ma ahimè non ma scusa ma non c'è un
finale mamma o non ho capito di proviamo
cnst frau e tumide giacomo abroad e
vediamo se capisco livello scusami
nattino detto ma non c'è niente a una
certa bilancio oppure guarda per andar
via non c'è un finale ho finito ma non
c'è o non c'è il traguardo a vedova è
che devo fà morto moio ecco che doveva
no no no e invece si andrebbe molto mite
giacomo me brother grazie per il
supporto grazie mille brother è però
plan bounce mannaggia kat
singer mannaggia e chi so io
eccolo la perfetta ne sto facendo tanti
ragazzi perché alla fine dopo l'ultimo
facciamo la conta riguardino fatti è che
soltanto
non ho capito niente ma fa niente
andiamo avanti ragazzi tutto giusto
non ho capito nulla nulla retro estivi
set mi sono pagati in mano voi comité
già come brother e andrea pepe fa la
media al via giorgio grazie brother
grazie mille eccoci no no a troy
è amica perché ero incastrato in un
azione è evitare però devo evitare
qualsiasi azione capito oppure prendo
store altro stock app store azzurro dire
bellissimo che tattica studio si che si
chiama allora ci sono varie materie no
sei studi è più iss
nella prima si chiama psicanalisi
livelli
cioè tu guardi il livello ti fai un
analisi dei dintorni di quello che c'hai
e capisci effettivamente cosa vuoi fare
che cosa no questo era grazie a fini la
persona lezione si terrà domenica
prossima ragazzi ricordate lo ok tutto
bene
ecco questo è veramente difficile più
canto perché non devo fare niente io se
non soffrire sperando nel mio
personaggio di va perché non è che posso
farci niente
sai tipo un flipper e come fa ecco è
come quando l'aquila palla nel flipper
cade nel mezzo
tu non puoi fare niente cade nel mezzo
avrebbe iva
dipende tutto l'assalto iniziale poi
dopo in tutto una un'ansia nel sapere se
vincerai o meno peccato andando a far di
meglio
ma già il card sto bene tutto a posto
chiaramente difficile raga
a
ma tu o mi sono veramente dovuto
concentrare raga qua è perché non capivo
quindi ho potuto 6 la pillola di come si
dice di limitless con la rete ma news il
100 per cento del cervello è uguale o
usata presso livello se vedete tanto si
chiama più di paypal più spikes e niente
quindi veramente spremuto i neuroni fino
all'ultimo ha funzionato bene allora
tanto sul livello aperto boss cus e ho
detto tutto
don bosco signori era il gamer che
andava di più nel mondo insieme a più di
pai ai tempi erano privi paletto morti
questo box
non ho idea del motivo è sparito sparito
nel senso che ha continuato a fare video
ma una certa completamente scompare non
ho mai capito il motivo è da tanto ma
tanto in modo esagerato esagerato
strano era il secondo youtuber c'è dopo
vivai più seguito al mondo
bossi su una volta in un suo livello mi
ha anche nominato perché ha fatto un
livello fatto permesso
c'è una grave sono il titolo per fa vj e
lui aveva urlato papi times ragazza
stava nota ricorda ovviamente nessuno
vorrei rivederlo quel video però
purtroppo nel tempo l'ho perso vedo mi b
mica ve lo ricordate mori vi ricordate
anche di questa cosa se ve la ricordate
sta cosa gira temi il video di tovo scus
dove chiedetemi il titolo le video di
the office dove dice farfa vince ma non
lo so ricordar nessuno è veramente
impossibile era veramente si va dal 2013
mi pare quindi figure gli ex ai
direttori
io me lo ricordo bene mi girato il video
no guardi in live
state calmi mio dio
insomma meglio mollare prima di urt qua
no sbaglio a prescindere va bene se
riesco a mollare prima luke lui si fa
tutti i razzi o quelli vado vado di di
di vado io dopo ho capito quindi se io
che riuscisse a partire no staccati uk e
stacca distaccati stacca distaccati
stacca distacca di sacca di staccati
bambino inutile state di ok ok ok c'è
quasi mio zio o
luca aubert convinta già sono caduta
un'altra parte questo mito e giacomo
comunque perfetto sono ancora vivo però
alla fine sopravvissuto solo gli occhi
mamma mia che pessima idea usare il look
e il padre ce l'ho fatta subito come si
segue il personale ecco lo seguo io che
non riesco a fare colpo fallo con lui
non ha avuto successo luke ma non era il
personaggio principale
ero io
sempre di omessa rischiamo
oddio a posto
madonna ce la fa no no non ho vinto per
un niente perché era arrivato alla fine
a farlo partire tutti i razzi prima che
si erano scontrati tra di loro a caso
peccato avevo fatta comunque la tattica
rimanere a lato ragazzi non c'è niente
c'è quasi niente
[Musica]
grazie alessio per la donation grazie
mille nessuno ricordava aiuto bossi
ovviamente era uno dei youtuber più
grossi del mondo è andata mi ha nominato
in un video bellissimo ho fatto nello
rimanere a lato come fuori di isaac è
esattamente quello ma come fai a
prendere la moneta scusa mi devi usare
il razzo no
ho capito vabbè ma come la prendo ma non
puoi medie capita se vai così veloce che
fai ma non ce la farà mai
non è impossibile
e son curioso scusatemi raga non ha
senso ma come dovrei mai prendere dal
pavè chissenefrega
diamo normale volevo provare la moneta
ma secondo me non si può prenderla
moneta no questo è molto buono yes
[Musica]
wow nights in white per sempre
[Applauso]
madonna se non escludeva quella avevo
fatto tanto di velo si chiama si sia pur
russia tutti i russi piccola vodka
cattivissimi sono vivo come facesse un
piede san pietro tra to piede c'è solo
un arpione ragazzi normale
amministrazione
già solo un arpione in tutto questo post
a morire col soffitto col soffritto
[Applauso]
mamma mia ma dai ma non è vero
nat grazie mille per il super sticker o
meno felici per sfiga la traction per me
vale coppia super sic e valitutto guarda
che roba
come ho fatto a vincere così adesso
verrà in tempi sono intanto o vinci che
non te lo meriti comunque in passivo al
cento per cento avendo bene ottima la
partenza comunque è niente
la trottola
benissimo next one ma ciò che è bello ma
che gioia ma che è bravissimo
ma porca vacca
no non sbagliano volevo non volevo
uscire volevo vedere non si può cambiare
personaggio non è vietato uscire negli
importi in giornata vietato uscire non
avesse mai non avrete mai pensato che mi
senta un debole perché non lo sono
milan tech insomma se fantastico grazie
nat pixie hartmann non ho capito cosa
voglia dire ma grazie alla sua mission
[Musica]
ma sì ma tanto vabbè il prossimo ormai
tv e avevo fatto un secondo fa questo
mannaia che ti fanno li copiano jones
ecco giunsi john cena ecco qua
john cena che vi fa ridere italiano
guarda a livelli facua fa v jump tra i
livelli famiglia non lo vedete perché
portava campero tagliata la la schermata
ecco qua o donna ecco
dov'è favi jump questi sei livelli fatti
la john cena è italiano ed è uno dei
creatori di happy with più seguiti di
happy wheels non so per quale motivo
cioè non è che anche su di alphabet non
aveva mai che non so per quel motivo è
veramente veramente forte e lui ai tempi
fece il livello che giocò bosco
scolorito dicembre 100 100 poco l'ho già
fatto facciamo questo ma [ __ ] yes
e vabbè è una propulsione di bombe e
nagel
ok
boh questo l'avevo fatto
l'avevo fatto nei livelli che avevo dove
facevo quanti forse con riesco a fare in
dieci minuti
questo l'avevo fatto a remember questo
mi è venuto in faccia tranquillo
mannaggia
niente paura riusciamo a fare un po più
tuttobici smi chi vuol dire è un po più
senza fare casino
bravo svieni o è le bombe ce le siamo
levate tutte basta non prendere le spine
tanta arte anche fornendole sure the
best cliff thank you for dei donation
ragazzi grazie mille per le donation che
mi sono meritato questa vittoria
meravigliosa
adesso tutte le altre bombe non sono
saltate sarà veramente impossibile
ho finalmente un livello finito
o è saltato tutto tranne due bombe di
non prendere quelle prende scritto ok
amen
è però ce ne sono ancora torna ragazzi
quando sono così sono veramente troppe
suo nome non riescono stesso ok sporca
trottola ma basta
sto livello di merda grazie al di andy
ballava molto bene se finisco livello la
va benissimo la gara sul canale certo il
duecentesimo episodio ha voglia sono
cascato certo non lo tengo è consulting
noi ragazzi sto uscendo pazzo
ora vado ogni volta ogni morte un pugno
alla tastiera
ok ok non ci sono bombe no
mi sta spaccando la madre fa malissimo
sta andando la sinistra ragazze stavo
rotta
papà
che male mi sto facendo
non avete idea
meno male perché mi stavo spaccando è ma
tanto mi devo spaccare uguale
no
onesto
bene mi è costato un arto ma fa niente
abbiamo fatto tutto manca il 1 l'ho
fatto due l'ho fatto cosa manca a i tre
che sta qua sotto
ok la donna bellissimo
very nice per mais
quindi a parte la mano che mi secondi
sono perfetto di nuovo next one abbiamo
impulsivo jabla oddio queste quando mi
faccio la barba cioè il dolore perché la
barba non certo andata via la barba non
è più cosa mia non ci passo
semplicemente non ci passo come devo
passarci qua ma non ci passo mai niente
ragazzi non fatti veramente tanti o
madonna bellissimo che culo questo era
molto più difficili colori è sempre
bella fa vps povera tastiera massi
poverina che ha fatto lei martinat e che
sono marci parte donation cara grazie
mille
ma che ha fatto che ha fatto la mia
tastiera niente non aiuta 172 in un
secondo e 77 l'ultimo cielo nell ultimo
ma è l'ultimo di questa pagina
no sono usciti in fini fi vabbè ma si
può fare solo con una nota questa roba è
storia dove finisco sempre ti rifai
si vede che sarà un segno
ma devo andare molto più in alto solo
che non vedovi livelli
[Applauso]
non vedo i livelli non solo di son
finito ma basta a finire pilibhit è un
segno del destino questo vuol dire che
sono proprio lui
[Applauso]
ridicolo dopo quindi pagano mai e
difficilissimo ragazzi destino favi
seguiva è infatti c'era io non posso
farci niente contro le quando il destino
dice che sono più di buy è quello ho
l'ho superato funzione è più gli slot a
no mi chiamerà finale sporca l'arco fini
ragazzi difficilissimo
questo era anche un casino facciamo sul
gran finale l'aria abbiamo gli ultimi
dieci minuti ma diversamente dal livello
dell'egitto questo ce la faccio
[Applauso]
oh yeah
be nice e addirittura doppia vittoria
allora ho finito la pagina prima della
fine dell'ora dell'ora ho finito tutta
la pagina che sono 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 23 4 i 15 16
ok 32
ok 48
a 50 anni ma c'è scritto qua ma sono
stupido soci qua mi stavo contatto tutti
staff a udine 16 e 32 48 già scritto
soci quanta be nice
velina aspetta a of mine university guy
yes 50 livelli li ho fatti in 50 bp di
un minuto livello in media figo
andiamo per insomma eccesso perché io
pensavo di metterci di non finire tutta
la pagina
e invece siamo arrivati alla seconda
pagina che proprio rai o in un ora tanta
roba
cioè non ora 1 youtube non bravo così
cioè in un ora nessuno nessuno basta
rosa adesso va bene tutto ma not bad
ragazzi veri not bad proprio bene come
sono riuscito a fare neanche più uno
aspettato questi sblocca no adesso non
ne farò più neanche uno è quindi va bene
alla fine in un'ora hanno fatti sempre
50 ma fa niente
l'importante è esserci riuscito a finire
la pagina è stato pazzesco
ora che tantissima robinson gran gigi e
non successo apprendendo preoccupante è
entrambe le cose
caro gabriele stavamo dicendo ai ha già
chiamato al tallone
oddio la faccio la faccio so ancora in
piedi ancora vivo sono vivo niente sono
già passate tre ore
no perché non sono passate tre ore
effettive da quando iniziato è va bene o
male ho fatto una intro di dieci minuti
non va bene quindi le tre ore sono
effettive effettive signori e quindi
dovrà passare ancora sette minuti
no sei minuti e arancioni già il cazzo
scusate vino come sono finite in questo
frangente cristo santissimo allora
maggiolina erano ragazzi impossibile
come sto 5,65 milioni o che ne ho persi
ma sei pazzo io mi fai un infarto non è
vero
scusa un attimo perché stavolta a
leggere i commenti io io leggo i
commenti e reagan e che non riesca
rispondere a tutti ma non sono a 585 mi
chiama che mai rilevato 200mila iscritti
mari morta ci guarda mi sono pagato in
mano ma che non ci arriviamo più se
andiamo all indietro
non è vero raga mancano 150 mila
iscritti chiamate tutti allora con chi
va a 350.000 iscritti gli ho fatto in un
giorno 24 ore quindi se i farisei domani
andiamo a 2 al 6 mila dischi nudo non
possono essere nudo nevi
poi divenne quali è uno scherzo che però
no
non la guarda oddio dio dio e che cos'è
che che chi è questo perfetto sbagliato
no ragazzi incredibile ci ho messo sei
anni non è impossibile che fino ad ora
non aveva detto niente
c'è un po sì però dicono non ho mai
stato sul livello sono così tanto se non
questo e poi quando laga gli ultimi
cinque minuti di epix della storia poi
finito nessuno giocherà mai più non
giocherò mai più 20 se non sto
scherzando la cattura state tranquilli
sono gli ultimi minuti del 200esimo
episodio che centro questo gioco mi
vuole male
in tante sfumature e non sto a elencare
vede ci metterei tanto
ecco
davvero sarebbe finita così ma sapevo
anche che avrei preso la moneta con gli
arti spappolati quindi tutto a posto
oddio questo trofei se veramente brutto
se posso permettermi perché l'hai fatto
così male agli occhi storti c'è un club
e orc a vacca che male e forte frutti
gang che potete un ace bellissimo
non è vero mai nella vita tu sorella in
autostrada
e vabbè allora non facciamo noi ragazzi
difficilissimo questo ma nella seconda
pagina avete messo i più difficili ma
che avevo fatto infatti un miliardo in
dieci secondi questi sono impossibili
veramente ma scusa a right price
[Applauso]
[Musica]
tre minuti e mezzo fa mi bene che c'è
una sete a me risulta che nei cibi di 86
a meno male allora mancano 140 ne
abbiamo fatti 10.000 i cinque minuti
perché non continua così ragazzi create
account chiamate amici create amici
create chiamate account
fate quello che volete ma supportato il
mio canale che saliamo a 6 milioni
faccio video con i contro
non posso dirlo ma faceva rima try to
survive
ai bomber quintegia come prova del ma
grazie grazie mille lescot era un bowl
fall veramente strano questo non avevo
fatto prima
scusate ma no era simile io che avevo
perfetto tutto quel calcolo tutto
calcolazioni possible challenge ecco
madonna che è difficile quel 9 ragazzi
ma che ripeto è ma sia spettatori
livello ma serio bellissimo a john cena
ecco perché brauzzi speriamo che tu stia
volevo questo episodio visto che sei
stato una pietra miliare di questo gioco
e dei video di happy luglio perfetto è
comunque madonna che vittoria pazzesca
mancano due minuti mi devo veramente
impegnare con un puledro perché negli
ultimi due minuti
devo provare a vedere quanti impossibile
scappare così che già questa è entrata
nella leggenda sono uscita fare in
un'ora tutti steam prossimo link e
incredibile però aumentiamo il record a
dismisura visto che ancora domicilio
proprio detto questo livello non farò
mai hard perché lenta proprio sulla
bomba porco il demonio proprio quella
fatto la tarato preciso per land aree
sulla bomba atterrare sulla bomba bene
rila
meraviglioso meraviglioso e non so cosa
devo fare e va beh è fattibile non c'è o
rais oscar olivieri welcome in de
giacomo l'ultimo ministro signori ma
dopo fattori manca un minuto raga dai ne
va non ci passo trita che ho fatto ho
fatto ancora ancora ancora ancora ancora
ancora ancora ancora madonna cacchio ma
dai su vivo ci credo trenta secondi
ce l'ho fatta ma che culo sono cascato
come sul traguardo ancora 1 rieccolo 1
madonna incredibile pazzesco
no ho sbagliato a cliccare
ne va beh mancano nove secondi si no no
allora è finita
ho provato ho fatto
tutto fatto in tempo però è forse era un
secolo ero un secondo dopo
mah vabbè tanto non l'ho iniziato alle
due precise ma le 201 quindi la città
ancora ma se voi guardate quella di
prima a raleigh che l'avvocato è la loro
toccato quindi valeva già signori non
l'ho fatto per un secondo ma ho iniziato
un pelo più tardi delle due e 0 0 0 1
quindi ci può stare l'oriente rientra
non solo per quel motivo ma anche perché
in quello di prima ero l'avevo fatto
semplicemente non mi ha dato il bug
comunque a prescindere
ho fatto 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
14 vanno a sommarsi cima tecnica 64
livelli di impossible in un'ora
se questo non è lo speciale di fb più
leggenda te che ne ho fatto uno da 5 ore
abbiamo fatto uno anche di un'ora
questo è da tre è una via di mezzo ma è
la via di mezzo con più chicche perché
ho fatto la prima ora le prime due ore e
solo livelli e pc quindi nella
classifica è l'ultima ora signori ma
cosa vi ho fatto dai questo è questo
lorenzo to poter riavviare almeno il 60
flight simulator serie legal non ho
capito niente però grazie
credo che tu stai parlando i flight
simulator e credo che tu stia dicendo di
giocare a flight simulator e viaggiare a
manaus che non so cosa sia volentieri
quando farlo prossimo letto il calo
grazie mille raffaele la donation che
misura il brasile grazie giulia per il
super ficher mega allora questa finale
di del 200 mt sordi e peace ho fatto
delle trovate se potete permettermi di
dirlo perché l'ho fatto grazie avresti
di essere stati con con me con noi anche
perché la fine siamo una grande famiglia
su happy with negli ultimi sette anni e
mezzo
otto anni alla fine perché ho iniziato a
giocare nell'agosto del 2012
siamo ad agosto 2020 sono un po con
bones però milioni in gradi di casa
perché è che è sempre stato il fulcro il
mio canale e siamo arrivati al 2
centesimo episodio 200 sembro di luci a
san siro
grazie a dami seguito raga grazie mille
di aver seguito l'intrattenimento
genuino fatto con passione alla fine
perché questo è il mio canale da sempre
non ricerco adesso è paul guys mi piace
farlo quindi io non ricerco per forza il
gioco che mi porta virus ma cerco il
gioco che mi piace fare fare primi sono
volte a settimana ci sta di più mi rompe
le balle ma una volta ci sta ancora e
questo vi fa capire che comunque io il
mio canale non c'è per me è un lavoro
appunto perché lo sapete tutti ma e
prima ancora una passione è nato per un
con una passione e morirà speronò ma nel
caso se moriamo lida con la passione non
finirà solo tanto per fare quindi se
siete da seguite mio cane dall'inizio
sapete tutto questo senza che io ve lo
dico ma lo dico spedizioni le ovaie ma
sto arrivando cacchio sto arrivando ai
la tastiera è arriverà alla fine della
mia carriera ancora intatta ovviamente
si parla del 2000 e 70 euro all'ora
rafael poiché gene x manaus presidio del
suo capito avevo capito anche prima
lo farò lo farò un promesso promessi
visto che dirò il mondo grazie ragazzi
per i dei commenti grazie x
a supporto di questa live non è finita
quest'anno le tre ore di happy with
adesso scoppola live vado da step né
entrò in live quindi ne crea un'altra
istanza perché questa live rimarrà
online visto che due centimetri crea
un'altra istanza della live
quindi stop ciao a tutti e chi vuole
andare e chi mi vuole subire ancora fino
alle 20 sarò su fall guys un bacino
grazie per essere stati con me per i
docenti episodio episodi a mille di
questi episodi